hopefully you'll be able to hear this
now Martin
okay
just a reminder that we are being live
streamed on YouTube the broadcast
remains will be going to our private
session and any public school in the
chamber at that point will he asked for
me
moving on to items one is the apology
apologies
yeah I'm leaving the same apologies
we've got Council of all and Council of
engines
thank you
thanks
thank you very much moving on to item
two declaration with images
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
opportunity interests and or other
interests not already on their
registered
in any item on the agenda I was talking
amazing at the appropriate time for any
members have any interest in declare
so
what you're doing
that
thank you
well
um
uh it's not saying so many presentation
thank you any of them
um
and then the northern icon um I have an
issue
I don't think
thank you
yeah
Declaration of interest
um
this explains there's no conflict of
interest that this particular point of
difference
but just to express them that I wouldn't
in any situation where there was a
family place
just on the on the basis
on are relative people although
um
thank you moving on to item three
minutes of the last meeting
yes
um
papers that we've received will be very
late so addition to the agenda I'm very
concerned about that
foreign
that's like we've got to be
this package that was bundle that we've
got here yeah
thank you John
in relation to the stone room Community
government to make it clear that that
was going to the wire and it would be
the one that would be very much for the
last minute so I can only apologize for
working multi-fact project together
since the 40th in November and there's
nothing
in relation to the allocation of faces
they have done so many reports on this
the figures change repeatedly
um now got to the final figures and
that's probably
in relation to the delay deal
um
absolutely again I'd like to error on
holding up to apologize I do apologize I
know this has been a bit of a movable
please is not if I'm completely honest
there's not a lot in there with an
update uh We've circulated some of this
before in terms of what we find out as
we found out so we've been an ongoing
story this paper relates to before
authorities
um developing a proposal document to go
out the consulted upon consultation
period began on the 14th of November I'm
a woman till January that this is an
update on for the ability respected
there's going to be weeks we've
understood and be able to
um
right I appreciate as soon as we get
these reports out of the bathroom
before
being suspended approached with you
today
moving on to item three minutes of the
last meeting
held on Monday the 12th of September and
from Monday the 3rd of October I would
like to take them both together
on are we all happy that they are the
correct direction
all those in favor
close the gates
any extensions
okay thank you
is that the motion has been carried
thank you
first announcement
um very brief because people are very
full meeting today this month was
certainly been a busy one for me having
many differences
these roads were taken fast in the
planting the tree it brings benefits to
become too far beautiful day
volunteers sector that eventually
growing information is being also on
this morning's event where the
presentation pushes Empire Metals domain
on the scene being an award for the
voluntary work well done person
foreign
the big one would also be the Armed
Forces family done Sunday and I hope
hopefully that you will support these
events Thursday times provide thank you
item five please
thank you very much as you say we've got
a happy agendas I'll try not to speak
for too long
um there's been a very significant Focus
for cabinet uh recently on the cost of
living issues and I want to thank the
other group leaders for their
contributions to the recent cross-party
meetings on this issue and in particular
I want to thank councilor Kenyon who's
taken a real read on it from within
Kavanaugh
um Steve Lee is here today and will be
giving us a presentation on this shortly
which will enable all members to be able
to feed in any further ideas on what we
could be doing that we're not currently
uh to support our residents and
businesses so I'm not going to preempt
too much of what Steve is going to cover
but I think there are a couple of things
just to note at this stage uh firstly
that the Northeast African news was
recently published which hopefully
you've seen and it includes our cost of
living special book within it there's
additional copies of that being printed
too for further distribution and it
really is full of really useful
information uh both in terms of support
packages that are out there as well as
being stuck with energy saving tips and
I'd all urge you'll members to try and
share that as far and wide as you
possibly can in your local patches
um cabinet has also just to proved the
recruitment of two additional community
outreach workers within the
environmental health team will be on
hand to support anyone who needs help
whether that's with managing finances
signposting for the support or providing
advice and guidance and I think our key
message to Northeast Armature is that we
stand ready to support anyone in the
district who needs our help one of the
most significant challenges of this
crisis is that the dial has shifted and
more people who might otherwise be
considered as financially stable and now
experiencing hardship
it's not just the more vulnerable groups
that we're struggling now but as a
consequence unlike our more vulnerable
Birds we don't always know that now know
who and where the people are who need
our support
so we're seeking uh to capture some of
that sense of community Spirit and the
way in which people looked out for each
other that we saw during the covert
pandemic we need more eyes on the ground
and so we're writing out local
stakeholders like Parish Council
Community groups shopkeepers and
publicans to share some of that
information material uh with them so
that they can direct anyone they know
who might need our support to our door
and I'd ask that all members as local
champions in our patches help us to
spread this Mantra but if you or anyone
you know needs help please get in touch
and don't leave it too long before doing
so
I'd also like to say a big thank you to
all our staff and continue to pull out
all the stops to support our residents
and businesses during these challenging
times councilor Cupid and I recently
spent a day on a ship with some of our
fantastic reference teams we had a great
time despite the unpinting rain and it
was great to experience firsthand what
it's like to spend the day in their
shoes it was also really nice to see how
many residents do shop and take the time
to thank the team for small Justice and
kind words so I want to say a huge thank
you to all of them for working so hard
day in and day out and come rain or
shine and what's a mess with being
without them I also recently spent the
morning at drumfield Leisure Center for
shadowing the staff there and again it
was really great to see behind the
scenes how much work goes into keeping
the sensors up and running being able to
witness some of the health and safety
and checking systems that we have in
place remember that I left feeling
really reassured that our centers
operate like a very well-oiled machine
the staff were incredibly versatile
jumping into different roles to support
each other all the time and they were
all very friendly and knew our customers
well and we're clearly passionate about
the work that they do all were a real
credit to the council and it's easy to
see that why we as not to have a
district council are considered a
Trailblazer in Leisure at a time when
hundreds of swimming pools were being
closed down all around us we're doing a
range of further back to four sessions
with other teams in the coming weeks and
months and I look forward to spending
more time learning about the Brewing
work that our staff did thank you very
much
thank you
moving on to iPhone 6 the Armed Forces
employment recognition gold wall
this was a lovely evening
I think it's something we can all be
very proud of
as you know the council was awarded this
scheme but it was a lot of hard work
and used to present it to us today is
Bruce Spencer the East Building is
regional Employee Engagement director so
welcome to the council and thank you for
attending today's meeting
thank you very much indeed and a
pleasure to be with you today
um I know Martin is going to say a few
words in a minute and um one of the
things that you may well say to you is
about this award and how special it is
um there are six and our million
Employers in this country
there are 638 Gold Award holders
one of the things that when the
Secretary of State looked at this
application which was forwarded by
Martin
was that how positive it was and the
unrelenting support of the armed forces
that has come across the entire District
I put it in the top of the night I've
got 54 Golds across the East Midlands I
put it in the top 10 so thank you all
for all the support that you've shown to
the Armed Forces because the Armed
Forces treasured and they're
um they're everywhere in your community
there are veterans
volunteers they're a reservist but
perhaps some people here may want to be
spouses of people who are serving
overseas right now so I do congratulate
you I congratulate you for this
unrelenting support to the Armed Forces
wherever they are and however they show
up in your opinion thank you thank you
I'm going to now ask councilmember that
Martin's uh on our behalf because I'm
thinking work to achieve it
people
okay
foreign
thank you very much Bruce Council is
proud to be awarded the defense employer
recognition scheme Gold Award for
outstanding support the Armed Forces
community
as you say the awards are presented to
employers to demonstrate significant
support for those who serve
for veterans and their families
it's wonderful to hear that among almost
seven million Employers in the UK
638 have received the Gold Award we're
one of them
for this achievement is something to
celebrate
Northeast Derbyshire District Council
undertook the journey under a previous
administration
and continued ever since
this is evidence of cross-party backing
for a worthwhile endeavor
the council's Practical support for the
Armed Forces Community is recognized by
Stone
the leading provider of supported
housing the venerable vulnerable
veterans
stole appointed Northeast Derbyshire
District Council as a housing hero for
its work to help veterans faced with
homelessness
to find safe and secure housing
the council officer leading this word is
himself an army veteran and Armed Forces
officer champion
other services we provide for include
the Armed Forces advertising
our vacancies are put on the career
transition partnership and forces
families job website
employment services to our community
employment advisor who attends the DWP
Armed Forces Hub in Chesterfield and
referrals for assistance with home
accessibility through the Home
Improvement team
each year we post a flyer to every
household in the district explaining our
commitment to the Armed Forces community
and encouraging eligible residents to
register as members of the Armed Forces
community so that we can help them
access grants and home adaptations as
well as encouraging businesses to make a
pledge to the Armed Forces Covenant
we send Armed Forces Community
newsletters and regular bulletins to
those on the AFC contact list who share
relevant information
as Armed Forces Champion I have attended
numerous events this year including the
Armed Forces hubbing Chesterfield
tsdnec connect to the 331 Squadron Aria
Cadet the Buxton military to two
organized by the Royal British Legion
and various events for the poppy appeal
including the Chesterfield Festival of
remembrance and rotary poppy ball
I am proud to have implemented the role
of Civic cadets for this Authority
tasks include support for the chair and
Armed Forces champion on Civic occasion
assisting and fundraising and promoting
the work of uniformed organizations in
the community
they are fantastic ambassadors for their
units
representatives from the council are
attendees at events such as the Stanton
conference information about available
support in the armed forces community
and the Buddy Buddy group a monthly
social Forex service Personnel held at
Chesterfield Football Club
both events underline the need for our
support
Northeast Derbyshire District Council
has a regular Presence at the Armed
Forces Hub in Chesterfield to network
with military organizations and
residents to showcase the services we
offer the Armed Forces community in the
district
Council commemorates on Forces Day
Armistice Day remembrance Sunday and
other important days
we place their homies in local Leisure
centers to raise public awareness and
remember the Fallen
the council chair and myself as Armed
Forces Champion attended Parish Council
remembrance events across the district
in 2021 we coordinated an armed forces
Covenant celebration event at drumfield
Sports Center
which included a remembrance service
attended by the Vice Lord Lieutenant of
Derbyshire the high Sheriff of
Derbyshire veterans and other
dignitaries
it was a splendid day
looking ahead we are making plans for
the chairs family fun day in May 2023
which will raise funds for supper
this is being supported by Council
officers and will include a presence and
displays from the Armed Forces along
with emergency services
practicals and entertainment
we all came to build on our successes
today and look forward to continuing our
work with our partners residents and
other organizations to help deliver on
our ongoing commitment to the Armed
Forces community in North East
Derbyshire District
thank you
thank you
I am going to open the floor if anyone
else would like to make a comment
people
oops
I'd like okay
thank you just very briefly to thank uh
Bruce very kind and through the
attendance today and for being with us
here and also thank you for uh Martin
for all of us
as for example we couldn't have a better
Championship within the council if we
think we tried and also thank you as
you're alluding to Steve leaving from
the officer Champion for all of his work
in the background as well so big things
you're involvement and really really
proud
substitute
yeah just just do I feel that I think I
think Marty being uh
what we're doing where yes
we've done that and uh it is a a good
thing for the council that we're
involved with all that and I like a lot
thank you everybody
Bachelorette
foreign
and if everyone is happy with that and
we agree by
what we need
um
thank you
moving on to item seven the evolution
the deal update
um
councilor Dale
thank you yeah um in terms of the paper
itself you'll note that it's uh it
summarizes the background how the
current deal has come about
as well as the content of the deal and
the proposed governance as Lee y echoed
you know but really sorry that the paper
has come out as great as it has
um but it doesn't I don't think there's
anything new that you won't hopefully
already be aware of I've tried to send
out updates as I've received them I
think that's the last time I sent out
the the full uh consultation document in
The Proposal of documents so hopefully
most of that you'll have seen before
anyway uh and I know that
um there will be a range of views within
the chamber about the deal and what it
will mean for our residents and the
district as a whole and therefore in
terms of the recommendations I felt was
the fairest and best way to capture
these views and then feed them into the
consultation but to allow all members
they wish to to speak to State their
views uh during this debate and then
capture those comments by the minutes
and submit them as Northeast averages
consultation response so I'm happy to
move the recommendations uh that firstly
that we note uh 1.1 and 1.2 and then
also so that part of the recommendation
number two that we submit those comments
from that we're going to hear from
almonds in the chamber uh to the
consultation
um I thought I would pick us up Yeah by
stating my own view because that's okay
I think having moved the recommendation
um so I think I've said before from my
perspective that I'm not particularly
fond of the mayoral model of governance
for all the reasons that I think many
within this chamber share that view I
wish that it wasn't a requirement of a
meeting called The Evolution deal and an
alternative lesson uh like a rotating
chair for example was able to be adopted
instead
but unfortunately we know that that
won't fly with government in order to
access a deal on this scale and with
these Powers accepting a directly
elected mayor is a prerequisite so then
it really comes down to a balanced view
is opposition to a mayor a red line
which we should not cross or is
accepting and there a price worth paying
in order to access the deal and the
significant investment in our region
that comes with it and while I've mixed
views on balance I fall into the latter
category for decades and by successive
government these Midlands has been
underfunded in terms of our
infrastructure now I see that firsthand
in terms of Education funding when we
compare ourselves to more of the
metropolitan areas but it's also true in
things like Transport Funding
for me it doesn't feel right to bemoan
these facts and yet then fail to take up
an opportunity like an evolution deal to
address that imbalance
the 38 million pound uh per year deal
when coupled with uh several other
funding parts and the additional powers
to help unlock our growth potential
could make a substantial difference and
it is an opportunity that we shouldn't
shy away from it's also a starting point
it opens doors for further negotiation
with government so that we can access
further opportunities both financial and
in terms of powers
we know that those areas areas with
mayoral combined authorities tend to be
at the front of the queue when the
government distributes new funding and
in my view we need to be there with them
I've heard from some that they're
concerned all this money will end up
being directed at the two cities and we
here in Northeast Derbyshire will end up
with hardly anything and I think that's
a fair criticism of the d2n2 local
Enterprise partnership which has been
the mechanism by which most
infrastructure funding has been
channeled in recent years and I think
it's fair to say that they have put gva
above anything else and as a result
Nottingham adabi City have tended to
Bear bass and the funding has been
distributed the fundamental difference
though of the new County combined
Authority and the mayor who will sit at
the top of it is that they will be
directly elected by the region and
therefore be democratically accountable
and while I know that most people have
used towards the idea of a mayor
including my art my own are not
favorable we do have to accept the
fundamental fact that they will whoever
they are rely on the votes of people in
Northeast Derbyshire as well as every
other corner of the region the districts
and counties will vastly outweigh the
cities in this new Arrangement and I
dare say that any mayor who focuses too
much on the cities for the detriment of
the districts won't last long in the job
turning to the issue of Northeast
averaging District council's role and
place within the proposing arrangement I
want to specifically address the
concerns of those who fear that this is
the thin end of the wedge and the
starting point on the journey towards
unitarisation
if we take the leveling up white paper
and the Devolution deal itself at face
value it's absolutely clear that it is
not that is not what is intended there
are very clear statements in both
documents about the continued important
role District would play in the new
Arrangements this is not about
centralizing Powers upwards from
districts and boroughs but that
devolving power downwards from Whitehall
to a mayor and combined Authority it's
absolutely categoric that we are not
being asked after this Evolution deal to
surrender any of our existing powers or
responsibilities and if we were I
wouldn't support it
moreover the district council's network
of which we are a member has secured the
agreement of government to amend the
leveling up Bill currently going through
Parliament to give all districts a
consent lot on any attempt that any
mayor may make in future to absorb any
of our current responsibilities in
simple terms that means that if any
future mayor tries to take on our powers
we can say no and have that listen to
I've been in countless briefing meetings
over the past few months regarding
Demolition and it's been really apparent
to me that that all four of the upper
deer leaders really value the import of
the district and borrowers that's why
there was District representation on the
negotiation team with government and
it's why there is provision within the
new uh governance of the new proposed
governance model that we have
representation at MCCA level and quite
likely votes as well on matters which
pertain to District functions now
clearly no one has a crystal ball and
it's impossible to predict what national
policy around local government will look
like in 5 10 or 20 years but to those
who fear that this is unitarization
through the back door I'd say that that
was the desire of government this is an
incredibly unusual way to go about it
why on Earth would the government go to
the efforts of publishing a white paper
which sets out its ambition to extend
the evolution to two-tier areas while
keeping both tiers intact and then go to
the extent of taking primary legislation
through Parliament to enable mayoral
County combined authorities to be
created for two-tier areas like these
Midlands if the government secretly
wanted to achieve local government
reorganization why would they go to such
efforts to do the opposite why not just
embark on a program of unitarisation now
my own personal view is that this
apparent threat of unitarization being
discussed in some quarters doesn't
really hold up to scrutiny but I go even
further than that I think my honest view
is that the Do Not Apply option poses a
far greater risk for the future of
district and Borough councils if we fail
to engage in a meaningful way with
evolution
try to add value to it and demonstrate
why our involvement is so important for
the success of the region then I think
we will be contributing to a situation
where unitarization is more likely in
the future
and while I know that change is
difficult we cannot and should not stand
still we need to adapt the changing
landscape to ensure that we remain
relevant to bring my remarks to a closed
chair I do understand and respect the
fact that many members have their doubts
or concerns over the direction of travel
and there are several aspects which I'm
not entirely happy with myself
but on balance having reflected all of
these issues in some detail over the
past few months I've come to the
conclusion that we have little to fear
from this deal but a lot that we could
understand again and ultimately my
honest view is that this is likely to
happen whether we like it or not my
absolute priority while ever I'm leader
of this council is that whatever happens
and under whatever Arrangements we move
to in the future I'll continue to
Champion Northeast Derbyshire and make
the strongest possible case I can to
ensure our residents and businesses
benefit from the opportunities that
become available thank you
thank you councilman Lewis
thank you uh chair and um
doing so just to say that I'm really
pleased that we're doing this
notwithstanding of course the gun
searching our surrounds that let me know
the difficulty about issues relating to
planning and official wind farms at the
moment and we all know that this
legislation includes uh evolution
however I'm hopeful to work through
um to either disaggregate or get on with
it but nonetheless these were having
this opportunity to discuss here at
District Council and that the debate
here um
payroll County combined Authority and
the debate here will be necessarily
different well um as it will be from the
one that will hold it to the county and
I'm discussing
what I must emphasize in this is that
this is a Midlands mayoral County
combined Authority and I emphasize that
shift from the previous situation
empty therapist
and I'm sure the views here um expressed
will be constructive forward-looking
not applied in the debates of the past
but we'll look outwards beyond the
confines of committee rooms Party
politics and be about seizing the
opportunity to make a real difference to
Residents lives and livelihoods to make
real progress investment infrastructure
transport Green Technology and to speed
up decarbonizing our economy and really
level up for Derbyshire and East
Midlands
Northeast Derbyshire has been one of
those Left Behind areas whose rested so
resolutely and decisively voted for
change in recent years because they want
to see us make a difference making the
changes right here in this chamber to
really level up
yes there are bits that we might not
like I'm not enamored of the idea of a
mayor any more than most people here
will be
but there's no significant evolution of
powers without one and the government
any government isn't going to involve
real powers or real money without one
you'll have to reluctantly a reluctantly
countenance one and the benefits I
believe outweigh the damage
to be clear we won't be having a mayor
that can really nearly do as he or she
pleases it'll be a mayor answerable to
the region through robust governance
which districts and borrowers will be
part of districts and borrowers won't be
seeking any powers the mayor nor any
potential development sites without
their consent
a concern that I've heard expressed
like all these things of this nature
there are me
myth flight planning and housing Powers
will be concentrated in the hands of the
mayor which is simply not true
they'll stay right here with Northeast
District
people will ask well what about police
forces police and crime Commissioners
and fire authorities well at this time
due to the complexities of two force and
two Fire Authority areas undergoing
other changes right now there is no
immediate requirement to look at how
they could be devolved
it will be for a mayor from 2024 if we
get there to discuss with those um
forces pccs and authorities
what the plan is and whatever is agreed
would unlikely be enacted before 2028.
as I said districts and borrowers are
Partners in an MCCA retaining all the
cards that relate to their powers and
functions recepting Powers I'll see
there's another area where Mayors may go
road but again these can't be enacted
without the support of the MCCA
of the nine or so nccas out there only
two have elected to precept both labor
mccas so MCAS rather so it's not the
norm
remembering too that the male sit over a
wide area that includes two counties and
two cities maybe in the future will
include leicestershire and Leicester and
to be clear it cannot be one or the
other of those authorities it must be
both if it happened
this dilution of the mayor's reach
ensures that the robustness and need for
the local authorities beneath the MCCA
to deliver a very ambitious agenda that
may will no doubt have subsidiarity of
those Powers will be key to make the
MCCA work effectively in essence the
need for local delivery close to the
people will be more important not less
important
what you might say for Barry we have
another expensive layer of local
government and that will work
I would say to you that the cost of the
mayor are very containable
and that the value for money argument
will be unassailable
okay just look at the investment that's
pouring into the region I'll summarize
by saying that local authorities need to
take this next step in their evolution
they've grown up steps into the big wide
world and look and look up and seize the
moment that Devolution can bring take
those Powers share them use them Drive
the investment investment we need to get
good clean growth and better quality of
life Northeast Armstrong residents this
is the Once in a generation opportunity
and we cannot miss it and if we do we do
so at the cost of the future wealth and
prosperity of our residents thank you
chair thank you I am going to open the
door now for further comments I'm going
to start with councilman
thank you chair for those of us who were
counselors in the 1990s this is deja vu
we were told then that joining together
was better
no argument for this ever resonated and
eventually they moved to unitary
authorities was shelled
in the meantime schools of local
government offices feared losing their
livelihoods
stress was palpable important decisions
were put on hold and hours upon hours of
time were wasted on this project
we appear to have learned nothing
if collaboration is the Panacea why have
we not made more of East Midlands
Council
instead it has become a talking shot
where I think little has achieved and
decision making is
in the hands of a very select few for
all its years in existence what evidence
is there that working together succeeds
for significant outcomes
if Better Together is the solution why
has the local Enterprise partnership
been of no real benefit to the people of
Northeast Derbyshire
access to funding for our communities
seems non-existent
instead money appears to have been
swallowed up in projects for the cities
of Derby and Nottingham this should be a
warning to us
proposed meralties for greater
Lincolnshire Norfolk and Suffolk were
abandoned When the evolution deals in
those areas collapse
people saw the light during the process
unlike here where this has been done to
us and not with us
if this project is so compelling why has
there been no meaningful engagement with
second-tier authorities
while we told that this is a fatal
complete and we have no right of veto
why are the opinions of councils such as
balls over and South Derbyshire ignored
when they say no to a combined Authority
the first combined Authority we
established was greater Manchester
combined Authority in 2011.
how many times have we had to see Andy
Burnham go back to government for
additional funding
the next additional combine authorities
were established in 2014.
one of those was Liverpool City region
it's a matter of public record that
merseyside police conducted an
investigation into Liverpool city
council resulting in a number of arrests
made on suspicion of broad bribery
corruption and misconduct in public
office and government intervention has
been necessary
you can't tell me there haven't been
repercussions for that region
what about Sheffield City region where
the directly elected mayor has failed to
save the local Airport
so much for Combined authorities being
great with developing transport links
how quickly we forget that Derbyshire
County Council launched judicial review
proceedings regarding Sheffield City
region in 2016.
I recall the campaign about local
democracy that we seem to have forgotten
now
how about the impact of the West
Yorkshire directly elected mayor in an
area that has seen one of the highest
repercussions of the cost of living
crisis
research shows West Yorkshire could see
up to 58 000 jobs lost next year leading
to an unemployment rate of 14
and 12 billion pounds wiped off the
value of the regional economy
so much for Combined authorities
in my view combined authorities are not
the Holy Grail of local democracy
they are the holy fail
it's just the destruction of Grassroots
representation in my opinion
I have nothing in common with anyone in
the cities of Derby and Nottingham and
they have nothing in common with me
we do not want the same things for our
communities
we will not benefit greatly from a
combined Authority whose funding will
inevitably be swallowed up by the cities
both are facing financial difficulties
and Nottingham is currently on the
receiving end of government intervention
every elected member in this chamber has
a responsibility to stand up for
Northeast Derbyshire as a district
and ensuring a genuine Grassroots
connection with the people who put their
trust in US
thank you thank you councilor Barker
thank you
to be honest I'm a bit surprised to see
this on on agenda to be honest given the
divisive nature of the subject matter
and I'm sure
uh you know all about that well I'm more
than happy to debate it we're here
and but we all except that there's more
money on the table from central
government which we obviously very
welcome of but it has got these strings
attached which have been flagged up uh
and that I don't think that's where you
draw the line that that's the thing
isn't it personally I can't understand
why we need to set up another tier a
local government I don't if there's
extra money there why can't they just
allocate it around to the councils that
are already there
uh on a priority basis then we get our
share and I think it's been been muted
about linking up me down this year and
Nottingham and Nottinghamshire I think
you know we're all thinking that we're
at Central University Northeast
Derbyshire but but we're a long way from
Nottingham City Center and the problems
that that they've got
uh so
it seems obvious to me anyway that that
all the resources are going to end up in
I know you've said that you know if they
get voted Randy and all that so it's a
trusting whether we believe that or we
don't
and our country northeast Asia
benefiting from this arrangement
and I'm not constant uh convinced about
the concept of a mayor either it does
set up another bureaucratic body that
will need funding they'll need officers
to support them they'll need other
things to do that which you'll need
funding and I know you're saying at this
point it won't be a precepted but in the
future I think it will and I think
because this Gwen for that is that it
will lead to reorganization of local
government and that that's the the
bottom line it might be if I think 10
years down line but it it'll mean the
abolition of
districts and boroughs like ours and I
don't see the people in Northeast have a
[ __ ] I think you'll read to it there the
the destruction of local democracy
because the further you take them
decisions and people like us away from
the local communities we live in that
they're less that people are going to
buy into that is that enough now when
they know us and otherwise they're going
to vote for somebody from Nottingham
that they've never seen in their life I
can't see that's happening so that's
where we are and I've also and I accept
the resolution that's on there but I
don't think that was far enough just
listening to the viewers of people here
and feeding them into the consultation I
don't think it says enough so I've put
together an amendment to that resolution
uh which I've I've finished the
equivalent to team with I don't know if
you want to distribute that now there or
rather me read it out
but that is full page as well
it just goes along the line and people
want to say sorry to that
it
I think it it and then we need to decide
what we do with that ultimately
I thought this were easy to try to write
it down
but
all right
Liverpool like that
[Music]
foreign
that's my concern and then it speaks
about these National development
management strategies that's the power
that I think will be will be devolved
down from central government for this
mayoral uh capacity so this power is
going to be devolved to the mayor now
when you look at what it says in the
leveling up white paper it says that
it's quite important to me that the
national development management strategy
has primary State over the local plans
so you're not necessarily losing housing
your local plan another plan another
strategy will have house over our local
plan looks like the relationship between
neighborhood plans and local plans
taking Primacy over those is exactly the
same thing now if you look at that
leveling up paper that's gone through
one of the one of the Amendments put by
Theresa Billiards was to reverse that to
give the local plan privacy over the
strategy so it's all about who's in
charge and when you look at this it's
all about control and power all the way
through now
how would the mayor get any District or
any Borough to agree we'd be briefed and
we'd be briefed over and over and over
again would be consulted on over and
over and over again like you've got some
Choice a business case will then be put
forward this is how it works and then
it'll be a carrots and a stick it either
be extra funding or it'd be the
withholding of investment so you felt
like you couldn't make any of the
decision so this is drip drip and that's
exactly what it means about control and
power if you don't get that read the
32-page document and you'll see those
two words over and over and over and
over again control power control Power
and that's exactly what it is when we
end up signing up for this I know we
don't as a district council but we end
up getting this put over us what will
actually when we actually look back and
read it I think oh crackhead that's
exactly what he said sorry
now lastly when we look at investment
the figures are 13 million and if you
times the amount 30 years they go into
billions absolutely but 13 million when
you share that out about the 2.2 million
people is 17 pounds each
exactly works out at 17 quid each that
can't find Authority has also got as
we've as we've heard I've got tax
raising Powers now he's not going to use
them but it will eventually as Council
of arcus said so so for me it can raise
its own presets it can also raise a tax
on the business rates as well and that
but when it comes to that that 17 pound
will mean nothing it will mean nothing
when it comes down to it because it's
another layer of government that's the
worst of it there's two things for me
it's a fifth layer of government
yeah or we lose another language anyway
places some less and less so it's there
and lastly there's the SPF coming in too
that goes over there that's 2.6 million
we're expecting sometime over the next
three years they'll be in control of
that that won't come to this District
that'll be Derby and nothing on the
trail girl and lastly I'm grateful that
we have got a free vote on this if you
like and these these labor amendments
are exactly what I wanted to express
exactly what I wanted to tell to uh you
know whoever's listening
thank you
foreign
National role at work uh and a lot of
that is in Manchester great Manchester
born in West Yorkshire and
it is just my opinion these these Barrel
things in the area where I try and
recruit them they just don't seem to
work uh they're not very welcome in
particular areas I have concerns about
the word significant investment because
I've got strings and where the money
goes and given the proposed amount for
the footprint of the area that all could
merge together it's not worth money
across across the we order a large
geographical footprint of the of England
this this proposed Council will do and
that's not a lot of money to divide
amongst all the little bits and the
large bits in the city it is much money
in my opinion and I also
the comment about the we would hold the
power of the mayor to stop him doing
things that I don't think and one could
be replaced but it would the worries it
would only then be replaced by something
that was going to do exactly the same
thing so they're my opinions I've kept
them breathing it just I have great
concerns with this I mean I've been
reading some of it as I kind of imposter
I I agree with what council Packers have
to say and uh it might go against going
to say a little bit of what council of
Marcus said as well
thank you thank you thank you
that's right a bit Foster
thank you very much and I was just going
to suggest that for the purpose of the
minute could we have actually Foster and
Mark roster just to make sure because we
don't always have the same views and
yeah surprise surprise yes
and I've got to say I'm struggling with
the Amendments and the reason is I was
quite happy with the motion that was put
forward by uh councilor Alex Dale that
we were putting out use forwards the
various views and because the
constipation is open until January 10 it
gives opportunities to to those of us
who are a dual hotel or Triple A Hotel
quadruple happens to formulate the the
their response properly and having
looked at every single aspect of the
point but I wanted to to talk about this
uh with regard to North establishes so
most of the points I was going to make
have been made already over them very
quickly agree with the principle of the
bringing more investments into the area
all of us will agree with that but I'm
not convinced that the Mayo system is is
the one that will facilitate that and if
we look at leicestershire and and
Leicester we've been mentioned they've
declined the offer there's a reason why
they've declined the offer they've
obviously looked at the risks and the
benefit and weighed up what was best for
their residents and decided that to have
a mayor wasn't the best option for their
residents so again it's been mentioned
it's about powers to improve transport
are those skills training housing
environments and encourage the creation
of good quality jobs nobody can really
go against that so we all agree with
this but then it says people a greater
say about issues that affect them well
this is one of the issues that affects
people of laws establishment and there's
not been given a choice they don't have
a a
choice on whether or not they go into
the combined authorities but that's not
giving them the greatest say about
issues that affect them again but for me
I've become a counselor because of
localism is about bringing decision
making as local as possible and this to
me is contrary to that it's difficult
for me to support to support it it's
starting another layer of decision
making is taking that local decision
further and further away from local
people and it's been mentioned about
this this is the constant for me as well
I've mentioned this the potential of
extra local taxi raised by the mayor and
business trade as a supplementary and
I've said before that residents will
then pay for a parish council term
Council District a county and not a
mayor so it's making it more expensive
for taxpayers not cheaper so unless as
you can mentioned unless there's plans
which is not in this first drug that's
planned to remove one of the levels
under the district or the county or
perhaps the parishion terms you know in
future which would make it a bit cheaper
for taxpayers and governance would be
decided at a later stage when it comes
to the police and Trump Commissioners
I'm glad because as after consultation
with the Derbyshire constabulary and
Nottinghamshire constabulary so I think
it was to do your job complicated to
bring those police forces together
there's no appetite for that from local
police officers or um from the chief
Constable so but that is not to say that
it's not going to happen
and when you come to the fire service so
the fire service and the community
safety are more or less still under the
same Banner has plans for the uh combine
authority to discuss with the Fire
Authority police and crime commission is
to identify the appropriate long-term
governance model for Fire and Rescue
Services in its area but it refers to
the white paper and the white paper if
you read that on fire uh does say that
potentially the fire and rescue service
would go on under a mayor so there's
plans there but you just have to read a
couple of documents to find out what
verse plans are it's not explicit in
this paper itself and just a very small
point but again very important I don't
agree with the fire service being
brought together on the one half just
like I don't agree with the two forces
Nottinghamshire and Darbyshire being
brought together
um various reasons just to give you a
quick example and rescue Authority works
very well and they have a budget 39.5
million uh 21 22. nothing I'm sure 46
million however the total reserve for
double 15.7 million well Nottinghamshire
fire and rescue 5.7 million they do
struggle to manage their budget well
they've been they've been reported as
being in real trouble I think the Chief
Fire officer and councilors have said
that there's two million funding gaps
consistently and and one counselor was
quoted saying that it is looked at the
finance and regarding future plans when
it comes to Nottinghamshire fire and
rescue if our service doesn't do what it
needs to do people will die people will
lose their lives and I know their grand
job but just to say that bringing those
forces together is not collaborations
happy with our partners so we have to be
mindful of that
thank you Council Academy and councilor
Lewis thank you Chad yes I've had a bit
more time to look through this now and
in the spirit of the the amendment is
still about just giving feedback on the
consultation and given that we don't
actually have any any authority to do
anything other than that anyway it does
make sense I am absolutely I'm very
disappointed that we haven't had a
proper justification for a mayor
um that you know someone should have
written up why and there is good and
explain it to us that's not happened and
I I definitely also agree that the
geography with Nottinghamshire I don't
understand that so in the spirit of this
being feedback on the consultation
um I think I will be supporting that
Amendment
thank you councilman Lewis
and this has been a really interesting
debate um so far um I do agree with the
councilor Dale vote in order to give the
greatest latitude for this Council to
express their views I think the original
recommendation in the council papers is
the best form of doing that so certainly
can't support
the amendment I think that actually
helped ties the um the authority in
making a decent submission
and you know capturing all of these in
particular
um there's a few things that I just
wanted to cover off that's been raised
at various points on today's debate I
mean one of the key ones
um is that somebody raised that um 1.3
billion which works out at term 17
pounds per head uh within the uh within
the region
[Music]
um is is not it's not massive uh but it
compares to eight pounds per head of all
residents across the East Midlands
currently in terms of uh investment so
obviously across that off of this
um we then talked about the control and
power aspect and control and power being
um uh sort of mentioned frequently in
that document it is because I was
talking about bringing uh control and
power counselor
it just was beige sorry while I'm
covering off the the points that were
raised as well
so it's purely just about your comment
on the amendment okay bye
are there any other further comments to
be made Council version
excuse me so I just a couple of quick
points um councilor Dale mentioned the
lack of investment quite correct I
mentioned the lack of investment in our
area uh over the last few years
certainly over the last 12 years there's
been at least 12 opportunities foreign
for additional funding to be made
available uh to the problems that are
well known in our area
um Council Canyon says what's the
justification for a mayor the
justification is and it's bribery or
coercion uh if you want some money
you're gonna do what I say uh from
whoever's at the top at this point in
time not sure who's who's leading your
party at the top end at this point in
time
um we mentioned again uh Council Foster
mcarke mentioned the 17 pounds per
person uh I think that's shared out from
38 million that shared out over the next
30 Years what on Earth will 17 and
there's no increase no
um no no
um I'm going to increase the random
start and pass the back and I understand
it so what 17 pounds per person is going
to buy us into 30 years time goodness
only knows the other uh MF problem that
I had is the um he's talking about
electing a democratically elected mayor
uh I think Council Dale um reiterated
the uh the um Newspeak in the uh in the
in this documentation but democracy is
not going to give any people any any
individual residents in Darbyshire
Nottinghamshire where they are the
opportunity to vote on this the
consultation will let you say yes or no
and then that will be ignored by the
thousand people who want to impose this
upon us all so if we're talking about
democracy there's nothing in this
whatsoever at the present time let alone
any future problems that may arise thank
you chair thank you
are there any other comments I also the
body of Rights reply
thank you
I've got all sorts of fun here about
what I was going to say any of all
settings mainly uh but one of the things
I would like to say and it's something
that stood out to me when councilor Dale
introduced it with that off with one of
the words he said was it could improve
lives in Northeast Derbyshire not that
it will improve lives that's a big thing
for me Cubs are very funny word to you
so that straight away
worries me if you're using that sort of
language but again we talk about the uh
the money and how it's going to work
work out and the 17 pound it's gonna
come in 30 Years it'll buy you a packet
of crisps that's what it'll be buying
um the fact that we as counselors don't
get involved and we don't get a say on
this it's completely wrong that's not
Democratic whatsoever we've been elected
by people
to represent them if we can't then
represent them on this next body then
that's something wrong with that
another thing is the people of Northeast
Douglas you should have a say on this if
you want true democracy everybody that
lives in this District should have a say
on where we go with this
just before I came out I actually went
on this East Midlands Devolution site to
see what this survey was like
um and I'm sure they'll figure it's me
but that's uh completely at the end
You've Got My Mind
it gave you nothing it was closed
questions really so that if you press
one thing it will just automatically
take it to the next and it is not giving
you anything it's giving you no
information whatsoever
um
right now
yeah I mean it was I thought through I
mean I I have to say I strongly disagree
all the way through it because it's
pointless you know the whole thing is
pointless if you if you're
somebody that doesn't know anything
about what's going on here and you're
just a member of public you wouldn't
understand it so you'd probably just
tick agree because it sounds like we're
going to get all this money and we're
going to be able to do all these things
with all this money that we're going to
get they don't realize that how that
money is going to get split down as it
goes through and Northeast Derbyshire
will be right at the very bottom and if
by any chance Leicester and them change
their mind and want to come in or you
can forget Northeast Derbyshire because
there'll be nothing left at all you
won't even get a bucket of Chris so as
far as I'm concerned the motion the
recommendations that councilor back
brought through should stand and I'd
like us to take the vote on that because
they do cover what we have the concerns
about thank you
foreign
for that and I think the debate I think
it's been quite an interesting debate
the concerns and questions that people
have and I was I was on County a few
months ago and I supported launching
consultation on this as an opportunity
to have that debate on you know the
answers and those questions and to give
all those involved in you know the
opportunity to answer some of those but
I am a bit disappointed in the amendment
if I'm honest because I do I would like
the whole sort of minutes Etc to be put
forward
um but given the Amendments and the
detailing it I always prioritize
nothing's Derbyshire and so without
seeing the final offer of the deal I
don't want to prevent my ability to
express an opinion and take apart
especially stage but I'm also going to
say
um
thank you chair
Council Wilson
we can't hear you this year it's very
important okay it was a point of all uh
whichever way the vote goes on the
amendments
um you'll still be taking speeches from
the floor yeah
yeah thank you
just checking on with these notes
is that everything on the amendment
rights of advice even Nigel
I've got another knowing uh
well uh I think we can move straight to
the road I think we've got the general
line here
thank you
else nadale you have a right to respond
oh yeah no no no okay
anyone that's got the motion does have
the right to respond
so what's wrong it's not it's just an
amendment isn't it so you know
okay
we are going to be voting on the
amendment
oh
just they were all very clear
and this is going to be done by wrong
call that's correct in reverse order
and just to remind everybody once we've
dealt with the amendments there will be
another vote on the main motion so this
is purely
um a vote on the amendment
so I'll read your name Mark can you tell
me if you're fought against or at saying
councilor P Wright
councilor B right or
councilor Weldon
Council Thacker or Council Tate or
that's the stone Council strap and
Stevenson Council Shipman
oh have you missed one by the way
my apologies my apologies Council
windley um can you give me yours answer
please
Council Rock four cancer Rouse Council
row four Council Ridgeway
Council Relic
so
Council reader
Council Powell
councilor Potts
Council Platts
Council Pickering
Council parking
councilor Morley
Council Liggett or councilor Lewis
Council Lacy
councilor Kerry for
that's a Kenyan yeah that's the Jones
that's our hearts form that's a Hancock
for councilor Gomez really
councilor I've seen
answer for now for cancer and Foster
four you answer a Forster
counselor Emmons
councilor Elliott
councilor Dayton
foreign
that's a Cupid
councilor Cooper yeah Council club or
councilor Burkin
Barry or Council Barker or Council
Armitage Upstate cancer
thank you
very much
okay the motion well the amendment let
me get the words right the amendment has
been carried the Royal fault was 36 for
two against and eight extension
abstention
foreign
we'll move on to the main motion I
believe as amended counselor Walton do
you wish it was thick
it's Richard Council Richard Wilson
Gospel of belly and now I'm just
covering points already made but I think
it's very important I record my
opposition this top-down government
proposal
they're actually started these mayoral
things with referendum local democracy
because that's something that people
want and they're all turned down we're
all votes the games it might be
different if you're Manchester or
Newcastle but in general they've always
been rejected so it's top down imposed
and there's no Groundswell of local
support I've been a counselor for seven
years and this has never ever been
raised by any Resident that this is the
way forward its natural area of
government with Tax rating how are those
taxing rate Powers will come in
so it's an extra layer I can it will be
administered from Nottingham Nottingham
has absolutely nothing that it will want
to do with this area it's been touched
on that we also look to Rotherham
Sheffield other areas there might be a
bit Darby will get its share and they
might be a bit thrown to Chesterfield or
the Freeport M1 real uh rail area down
in the South but nothing will come here
um and so effectively you know D and
d2n2 I think was very disappointing um I
think it didn't work so why would this
work and in my opinion it will lead in
my opinion it will lead to the abolition
of the district council district
councils and again I've changed my view
over the years I think do perform an
extremely important role the higher up
the bigger you get you're counting the
superstructures the less accountability
there is between the counselor and the
and the and the electorate so although
you may say it's an extra layer of
government the district what we do is
important safety build and it's
important for locality that we are able
to pass over their opinions finally I'm
very concerned and it was touched on
with the interrelationship between
neighborhood plans local plans between
us leveling up bit and the introduction
of Mayors because this will lead to some
form of traffic light system and Mayors
where there'll be no local consultation
or decision making over major
developments in terms of new housing or
protection of the green belt thank you
thank you does anyone else wish to speak
councilor Shipman thank you chair
um I just want to say I'm very pleased
that that Amendment went through and we
haven't just sat on the fence and tried
to do all things for people with some
dark motion about let's explore all our
music because it would have convoluted
our position of the council they want to
don't want to listen to anything but
said it one Council of saying no foreign
by this government on some vanity
project where they want to install
Mayors just to get the money that they
could easily give out to local
authorities if the political will was
there so it would now pass this motion
and put on our opposition on record
thank you thank you anybody else
no okay so find My Notes all in the
right place we have a motion before us
to note the details of the devilation
deal with the amendments
included and the process for
establishing a combined Authority
and we're going to do this five roll
um
voting for the main motion this time as
amended
okay
the last vote was on the amendment this
is on the main motion as amended
without you
you can be as confused
make it there it's all right
everybody
wishes to vote councilor P Wright
councilor B right
Council P Wendy
councilor welcome
Tate
Stevenson
that's a shipment
four Council Rouse
Council Road Council Ridgeway that's
ceramic
Council reader oh that's a pound
Council reports
Council Platts that's a Pickering for
Council parking
councilor Morley
that's a Liggett for Council Lewis
Council lazy four councilor Kerry law
councilor Kenyan
answer Jones
councilor hartshorn councilor Hancock
for
eign
[Music]
councilor a foster
how's Emmons
Council Elliot
cancellation
councildale
uh I've seen that's the cupid
councilor a Cooper
for Council Club
Council Birkin well Council Barry or
that's a barker well Armitage
cancer
really
the motion with the amendment has
encouraged the result was 36 for none
against and 10 abstentions the motion
has been carried thank you
moving safely on before I lose my voice
completely
item Age cost of living response we now
have a presentation on the cost of
living crisis response from the
assistant director of regeneration and
programs so that is deeply and I suggest
that we let him visit the presentation
before any questions
statements
good afternoon everyone
um
thank you chair I appreciate about the
busy agenda who you've probably been
very active so I'm just going to give
you an overview the breadth of work that
we've been undertaking because of our
cost of living challenges that we're
facing as a nation so we're moving
strictly on and I've got a variant
background when they do the slides for
me I think next slide please Jenny
he's working
so to start with we're looking
internally so um as councilor Dale
alluded to earlier we've established a
chair's cost account across party cost
of living meeting just so we can meet on
a regular basis every three or four
weeks just to see how we're progressing
and to collect the ideas because we are
all living in together you know I've
personally found that a very true for
meeting and quite positive in terms of
the input from members around the table
but at an operational level we also got
an officer group meeting which brought
down to the the form of financial
inclusion group that we had so we've got
over sites at various levels to try and
take this very important matter forward
now the key thing for us is to take
immediate practical actions so looking
at this building uh with recruit some
energy Champions our Estates team are
walking around doing room by room
function reviews and checks reducing
their idle consumption which basically
means certainly things like that I'm
being used but um we're also looking at
reviewing the heating systems so we've
got everything serviced so it's running
a maximum efficiency but we're also
turning the heating off early during the
day whilst maintaining and sort of
Standards we would expect for staff and
also got some motion sensors in the uh
in every light within the building so we
must have been moving quite a lot today
uh whether we knew it or not because
every light now we'll see how we're
working and um
and that's what we've got across across
all of our facilities you know our
Leisure centers we've got LED lighting
across the piece and during the
accommodation review we're changing
lives ad hoc uh depending on when the
moves are taking place just so we've got
uh lighting that's fit for purpose
I should also mention the swimming pools
as you can see on the on the slides we
have the lower the temperature and not
rely with tolerances and uh yeah yeah I
can see there's some people I've noticed
and we'll measure that by the complaints
but we are removing the industry
standards so hopefully that's uh that's
also the good and also will save us
where they will keep the facilities open
so we can go serving the community
thank you so moving on to the next slide
looking at externally
um this is where we realize that we are
just one of many actors that are
supporting our community so there's a
rapidly public private and voluntary
sector organizations supporting our
residents and businesses and what we
don't want to do is reinvent the wheel
so the cross party leaders meeting is
very clear on that we recognize that we
need to be efficient and focused and
responsible in terms of where we're
focusing on our resources so what we do
need to do is find out who else is
working on on those supports and get
that message out there so we've adopted
the signpost for obvious reasons in
terms of what we can share with our
colleagues so information advice and
guidance is key we can get that out to
colleagues as I say but all types of
businesses and residents
we are keen on supporting and providing
practical assistance which I'll move on
to and also providing grants so some of
those grants will be to groups so we've
got the Community Action grants that
have been established for a few years we
will support for example warm hubs well
I've said applications for that or there
may be grants as well that some of our
partner agencies can give to struggling
households which we will continue to
publicize wherever we can
and then one of the things we are trying
to do is be uh flexible with our
residence tenants and local businesses
to create a flexible financial payment
plans we recognize people are struggling
the rates for energy costs are rocketing
and we're mindful that people come to us
early we can try and resolve and support
them balance their finances in the in
the short term and we'll do our best to
help
so next slide please
so going back to the same posting uh
we're about to start the uh the
bombardment of the information so we've
got thousands of these flyers in the
process of being printed which we will
make available to yourselves as
as members and um so you can give them
to Residents as you as you did around
we've also got some very small calling
cards as well which I'm struggling with
the cost of living help is a hand so
it's got our email address it's got our
phone numbers on so people can contact
the council so you can refer people on
because we recognize the earlier we know
about some of these challenges the more
we can do about it we don't want people
to hit crash this point before they come
to us we want to get in there early
because if we can't help we might know
somebody else who can and then that's
our key Mantra really
so it is the as I say it's getting that
message out as much as possible we were
we had a very high quality um edition of
the news went out recently with an eight
page special for the cost of living
crisis uh we understand that's been very
well received by our colleagues at
county level as as our website and
that's just giving information about
people reducing the bills and as you're
saving tips paying bills help a business
and useful contacts operating and it was
for services are operating across the
area so
um we do know we've had over 1400 hits
on our website we've got a banner on
every page which you can't really see
very well on the slides but
this red planet here that's everywhere
so people just one click away once they
come into the council to get that help
and advice or they can go on the school
just pick the thumbnail and uh we'll
we'll do our do our best to help
so we have got a range of other issues
on on the website because we recognize
that it's not just about funding and um
and Energy Efficiency that being scam
aware is key a lot of the funding
that's coming from the government
is pay that sort of stuff but not
everybody knows that and we'll and I
know I've received some texts saying get
in touch with me because we can help
sort out your rebate and we want to try
and burst that bubble just so people are
confident in how the processes work and
aren't taken advantage of by a bunch of
close people and we'll also got in their
help to mitigate for domestic violence
mental health challenges access to food
and more and more guys and some of the
world spaces initiatives because it was
loaded as a potential solution where
everybody saw it slightly different so
we've got different information packs on
there how to run a wormhub or then also
got some practical help and advice in
there and some of the funds that our
colleagues at w County Council can can
support all groups so we're trying to
get get that message out there as widely
as possible and the cons team are
working very hard to do at least five
social media posts a week with the top
tips so we're all grateful to them
um with the eight page
supplement that was in the news we are
creating a standalone document which
we'll soon be going out into the
community so as long as well as these
flyers and some posters they'll be
available in your local shops pharmacies
libraries I've got people going out
today putting those across the district
so they will be going out to parish
councils as well but if you needed
anything please get in touch with the
team and we'll uh we'll pass that on
so I've mentioned is the councilor Dale
alluded to the end of the meeting just
let us know and uh we can see where we
can help so that that's the information
and then if we move on to the practical
help that we can offer and we're
colleagues at retail homes are going out
and undertaking energy assessments uh
for for tenants and to offer practical
support so people in the most energy
efficient housing that they can um
that people can live in and uh
we are also collecting on the Warm Water
Gardens on the website it was alluded to
but what we are trying to do is put more
boots on the ground
so we've got two new community outreach
workers so to be in the recruits that
use an external funding so I've been
lucky to uh try to test out
and we've also come to an officer to
support our homes at home assistance
coordinator so that's again some more
help so we can get around to see more
more tenants and residents across across
the district and also hopefully local
groups for example luncheon clubs
our resident benefits team have been
very busy getting out the Energy rebates
and to all our residents so we've been
as reactive as we can to get that and to
get that out and we continue to access
them from our brand top actually which
is the home efficiences so uh bring
those homes are currently going to uh
hundreds of thousand pounds of bits to
uh to do to enter if I can mention that
name uh to uh to get some funding uh
into do some retrofitting for houses but
uh more locally we are also promoting uh
schemes such as eco4flex which
sounds a bit strange but it's not
strange when you're giving people money
to insulate your homes and get new
windows Etc so we've seen what we can do
to help some push the opportunities
and then finally the last slide we are
mindful that we want to keep our
communities thriving and keep our
businesses open so we have um I
developed a business focused Energy
Efficiency pack which businesses can
look at top tips we also were working
with colleagues across Derbyshire to see
if we can commission some energy orders
to be undertaken so people know where
they're where they're building could be
improved so they can harness all the
funding
and take that forward
and then
somebody mentioned earlier about UK
share Prosperity well we're still
waiting for the funding uh the clock's
ticking what I am happening assured last
week that it's the decision would have
made in due course so we have been
trying to be creative with that funding
so we have to put the bid in in July of
what we wanted to achieve but in the
meantime we've been trying to amend some
of the the rules and the guidance that
we want to um to include so for example
we've got a shot from funding scheme so
rather than just written out the shops
or now consider double glazed Windows
energy efficient doors Etc we've got
business advice schemes which will
include Energy Efficiency with their
encoded Energy Efficiency mitigations
whether that's solar panels or new
windows Etc in our community bedroom
Village Halls fund
and we've got some funding for the third
sector to deliver or inclusive
communities which again might be advice
and help and guidance for people who are
struggling within within the district
so we are continuously continually
looking to to evolve in the same way
that we've seen people to share
Prosperity so we're not resting on our
Laurels but um the key thing to
reiterate is get in touch with us if if
you do know of anybody with any issues
and if you've got any good ideas you're
going through that same customer very
well considered to listen to that thank
you
thank you I'm going to be opening the
blog counselor yeah yeah thank you
thanks Steve uh I've established in
other meetings and our research engineer
I don't think we can do any more than
what we're doing as a council I think
it's excellent way uh and I'd like to
compliment everybody involved uh the
leadership and obviously all the
officers
and 88 at that point if we know anybody
that needs help then let people know
because
you'll see it was best and thanks again
foreign
this is actually the benefit of people
working together rather than having an
autocratic one set of decisions it's a
success there obviously we can't have a
become a conversation but I think we're
moving in the right direction and all we
can try and do is get this message out
there and see how many people we can
help with it so thank you for everything
you've done
El Sarita
yeah Steve it's it's absolutely
brilliant work and I agree with what
you're saying uh Russ it's that cross
party working working together
um I just want to sort of comment on the
two community outreach workers Steve
um I think that's brilliant I think
you're going to fill their work many
many many times over
um with their role is that where they'll
be going out to actually visit people in
their homes and support them with you
know things like if they're struggling
with form filling that kind of stuff
because that kind of work
and I work in the social care so I
completely understand their work is
absolutely crucial because people can be
sat really worrying about something or
even not even understanding that they
are entitled to certain you know
benefits that they can claim they don't
get you know what they can actually get
to get that support that they need so
just having somebody that can sit and
and show them the way and give them a
little bit of direction is really
crucial but I think they're going to
have their work cost out yeah brilliant
thank you and if I can answer it that's
exactly the role is to go out and do
that trusted face that won't be in a
certain time necessarily release is
somebody who's going out there who can
help and hopefully they'll go viral so
they can give one of these cards and I
should have said that there's a box of
cars for each one of you to be able to
take today and um they can pass it on so
using jealousy is a motivator then Mr
Smith had it she's okay the council
supported it she's given me this card
and let's get it gets out there because
that's sometimes more effective healing
from a neighbor than it is directly from
the council
Ridgeway
device just a very brief one about the
documentations more than anything
leaflets and antioxidants I think it's
really good but my concern is what you
do
okay most people can read but people
there's people that are blind so are you
looking at putting Braille for these
people because that is something that
you know you have to consider because
they can't always access the computer
they may not be able to see the computer
and I think that's something that we
need to be looking at
yeah we always include the access
statement on on our Flyers so hopefully
people will have a friend or colleague a
family member who will be able to design
post them uh we do report I think that's
one of the reasons we go out through
social media and also the website
because people have readers which can
access the work online so everything
that we've got here is a piece of paper
is within information that we've already
got on our website the website is
actually better because we can update it
with two or three times a day so it's
it's as most recent as possible so
hopefully that somebody won't be totally
isolated in in terms of receiving the um
the message I think the only thing that
we're not doing is Radio broadcasts but
apart from that we are training every
Avenue that we can and hopefully by
having the referral cards where people
will talk within their communities that
that might log in and then if somebody
can can ring the council and that that's
their door in and we can sit down with
them on the phone to go through the
support links that they've got
any other questions to see
and then
thanks yeah just just really to let go
uh some of the thanks already really
grateful for the uh opposition group
leaders their their through the meetings
but in particular I want to thank Steve
himself who has really been a champion
for this and as it takes such a lot of
cross-council working and that one team
ethos that we always hear lee uh blurted
out about but but Steve's been the
absolute Benjamin of that because he
really has brought lots of different
um areas of the council together a very
ably assisted by Jeremy who has really
got the bit between his teeth around
this issue and has been really pushing
um you know pushing the council to do
more and more and and pulling this
together so yeah big thank you to all
those involved and obviously
as discussed we need all of us as
elected members to push these messages
out in our community so you support with
that we very much appreciated and if
there are any more ideas by all means
feed them in we're always open to um to
considering this thank you Jay thank you
there's nothing else Steve I'd like to
say thank you very much and thank you to
your teams brilliant work
and I'm sure we would all would like to
note those as the job well done thank
you
moving on to item nine treasury
management updates and
and I would like the leader of the
council to speak on it so that you
counted out thank you chair and so this
report provides an update on the
council's treasury management activities
uh from April to September for this year
and it's solely to note those appendix
one details the current borrowing
activity and interest paid on external
borrowing as well as providing an update
on the council's Investments and the
interests these will bring
um and you'll also be aware of the
current volatility in the economy and
this is impacting on the treasury
management decisions we're taking and
we'll need to take over the medium term
the finance team are working very
closely with our appointed treasury
management advisors to minimize the
impact of the interest rate exposure on
debt and to maximize Returns on
investments during this time I'm happy
to move uh recommendations at 6.1 and if
there's any questions of detail I'd
encourage you to direct them at Jade
are there any questions just type Jane
thank you Charlotte
questions
okay
delicious and say no no
so all the members are happy to agree
with this
thank you very much
has been approved
item 10 allocation and places to
committee
our agenda deals with the allocation of
places to committees it is a report of
the monitoring officers so I would like
Sarah Sternberg go through it for us
thank you chair I'm not going to say
much as members are aware the number of
seats in each political party has
changed and executions the latest
figures and allocation it is now put
each group to make their nominations to
the relevant committees
thank you counselor so I think you'd
like to say uh happy to move the
recommendations
um I was going to suggest that
um we delegate the monitoring office to
the uh the final movements of those
people by email if I were to email for
example the monitoring officer after the
meeting to say who was going to be
removed from what kind of thing you've
made those changes rather than full Camp
about to go through each different item
yeah
thank you gentlemen
because everyone happy with that and
then someone just thinking that yeah
okay
show of hands I think you want something
brilliant thank you
it's 11 stone groom Community governance
through you
this is the report of the drop
recommendation to the council the Stone
Brewing Community government
a member of the working group along with
counselors Richard Wilson and Mark
Foster in recent chair
so I would like counselor Foster to now
speak on the report thank you thank you
chair uh first of all
um following the remarks of councilor
Burkin earlier
um yeah absolutely I understand exactly
what it meant by uh it's quite a large
report and we answered a group of all
the time to look at it but uh it is all
in there and this is not the end of the
actual uh the actual consultation so
just in addition to what and one can
obviously said earlier uh the background
of this uh we received a valid petition
the council received a valid petition
187 signatures uh on a petition
requesting a separate Parish Council for
stone room and as explained at the last
council meeting on the 12th of October
the district council is required to
carry out a community governance review
after the section 83 of the local
governments and public involvements in
Hell by 2007.
a field room Community governance review
working group was set up with myself as
a chair together with councilor welcome
and counselor of office is working with
the group where Sarah Sternberg our
assistant director of money monitoring
officer and Donna javadar elections
manager who might be uh asked onto some
questions uh answer some questions
earlier later
and we again our managing director
our role as a working party was to
consider the consultation received in
relation to the petition request and
make draft recommendations to the
council which these are
as a group we followed guidance from the
boundary Commission on carrying out the
review and during the process we also
took external legal advice from
weightman's solicitors the legislation
itself sets out that the council must
ensure that the community governance is
within the area under review should be
reflective of the identities and
interests of the community in that area
and effective and convenient we were
also required to take into account the
following influential factors the
impacts of community governance
surveillance on community cohesion and
the size population and boundaries of a
local community and Parish
account a large part of our work that we
carry down to the group was the consult
um consult the electorate and the people
of the parish however whilst the
councils are statutory duty to console
the legislation and statistic guidance
does not specify how we do this so as a
working group we took the decision to
have a very robust consultation exercise
and do uh more rather than less the
consultation included
information on our own District website
including the survey and frequently
asked questions information on the
shearland and high-end Parish Council
websites are the same then we targeted
social media posts on to The Stumbling
residents including reference to the
survey that was something that was
reposted several times
um just to try and cover everybody
against many people involved in it as we
could
um a leaflet then was sent out to all
households in sherland and higham and
that included the survey uh likely the
stone room as well we then held a public
meeting on the first November
in stone room which was very well
attended
um we had around 50 people there a very
robust discussion
um some issues were raised at that
meeting to do with the first leaflet how
it went out uh we responded to that and
that was on the Wednesday we responded
to the uh the concerns immediately by
sending out a second leaflet including
the same survey which was hand delivered
by officers to all household in stone
group that was only four days later so
we were quite proactive and we reached
out as much as we could to get as much
response back from the community
uh onto the outcome of the the
consultation exercises we received a
total of 161 responses
and in terms of the electorate for the
whole of sherland and higham Parish
including still room and mickley that's
4034
now 161 accounts for four percent of the
electorate so all told we got the four
percent of the electorate reply out of
that 161
74 expressed a wish for a separate
Parish Council so the percentage was
there uh well obviously that if you take
it as it is 74 to the four percent
effectively three percent of the whole
electorate wanted a separate Parish
Council
as a group we didn't just look at uh
foreign against we read the individual
responses read them out on the table
read them all uh to get an understanding
of what people were actually feeling uh
some of those are in the appendices
which are attached to the report as
you'll be able to see
other relevant figures I think we've
already mentioned this already about the
50 people that attended
um the actual public meeting on on the
first November uh we knew where uh that
they were from the area because they
were asked to sign in at the beginning
of the meeting
uh one figure worth uh worth bearing in
mind for those that don't know the area
there's 4034 people elixirs in the
parish and out of those 4034
1472 I mean student rooms that gives you
an idea uh of How It's Made Up
the report details the findings
arguments and considerations into those
by the working group with information
also being contained with independencies
now to our actual uh conclusion we took
into account the fact that a petitioner
being triggered to carry out the review
187 people have signed this so there's
obviously a strong feeling there there's
strong feelings supporting the proposal
for a parish in stone room from some
residents
the response to the consultation were
limited to a very small proportion of
the local residents as I said earlier
four percent of the electorate and the
responses were mixed with a significant
number of those who did respond not
supporting change
I mean consider them weight of all these
factors we consider the communication
and identity would be best served by not
establishing a new parish for storm room
uh put simply there was no there was no
Groundswell Public Opinion uh it just
wasn't enough people it wasn't just the
quantity it was a qualitative exercise
as well so we
and get a response that we needed to be
able to come into this Council that we
set up that new uh Parish Council for
the film room so I asked the council to
approve this draft recommendation we
then take it back to the electorate
stage two so whatever these
recommendations are here if the council
agrees them we then take that might take
back for a further stage of the
consultation and then when it comes back
again Council uh in January and much as
it being said earlier uh I'd appreciate
any any technical Technical and and
legal questions uh hopefully they'll be
able to be answered by uh Sarah
Sternberg or uh
at the rear of the council chamber uh
I'll be up it's a couple other questions
uh when I reply thank you chair thank
you I would like to actually second this
motion and on behalf a lot of soul
searching went into this exercise and it
wasn't an easy decision but overall we
have to look at what is best to be a
literate and they're always forward
simple hands have gone up so I'll open
the floor with councilor Walton and then
councilor Lewis
and Council Barker
thank you chair thank you for taking
over my second thing of the motion as
well you relieved a burden from me
um
it makes it easy for me because I'd like
to make some comments which aren't
performing from the working group
there's some observations I made as a
member of that working group and in
supporting the recommendation in the
context I'm a great believer in locality
I really am but uh recognition is what
it is so I wanted to look at either ways
forward for those people who believe
that Stonebridge have a separate uh
separate Council or indecents of
accommodation which meets their needs
the first one is to know there is
nothing to stop the ref having a
referendum that's the district council
can't have a referendum but the parish
can so there's nothing to stop the
parish as well having a referendum on
this issue and obviously that would
carry waste next one is just an obvious
one
2023 your Council see what the
composition is what Manifesto of
individuals are and again although in
theory there's a two-year moratorium
it's not strict moratorium it can be
reopened if the district council saw uh
that there was you know a momentum of
views for this uh uh for this initiative
uh in this guidance which I think the I
was given by the the officers uh there's
a section here at the m146 community
groups Community groups I believe can be
members of Committees of a parish
council and Council can be represented
on community groups as well I know
there's groups like the Civic Society in
dronfield there's other groups that are
very very active they can be
geographically active
um onto some other ones uh you could
change the name Lobby to change the name
of the parish to include Stone broom and
Higgin and again to recognize that it
consists of poor villages
uh sorry thanks thank you for the
correction
um it's my handwriting uh and then the
next one is probably the most important
one thing you can apply for the parish
to become more rewarded Council awarded
Council and again I think uh what I got
was on the basis you know just a pro
former of 10 councilors two or three
then could be representing that Village
Stonebridge that would give more
accountability uh and it would recognize
uh the distinctive nature of the
villages and finally you could apply
again you have to go to the same process
of consultation to be a parish but not a
council that again would give you an
annual assembly of residence once a year
so they're all measures that can be done
either at the interim maybe are leading
to uh you know more support for the idea
of a separate Council or and even
accommodation to reflect the
individuality of the villagers thank you
thank you let me move on to councilman
Lewis
uh thank you very much Jay I'd like to
um record my thanks to the uh um the
working group and uh um particularly
council at Foster for a very thorough
um discussion and walk through the
report
um there as the year of the County
Council for that um uh division
um I do have a sort of some concerns
about this and um Council of foster are
articulator does really well about a
small number of people who engage with
this particular
consultation and then the very small
numbers of people that came forward I
would have longer term concerns about
the viability of any sort of particular
parish councils as they split um in the
in the future leaving relatively small
numbers of people and um people would be
actively engaged in the future Parish
councils
um as well
happened
so on on the whole
um listening to uh councilor weltman is
recommended his his ideas for you know
you know great kind of process and name
change
um looking at the warding or becoming an
active group that's focused on this um
some room I think is probably the
domestic Way Forward so overall I can't
argue with the recommendations uh within
this report
um and uh which once again I'd just like
to thank the uh the working group for
their work
thank you Council Barker oh thank you
again I I know there's been a lot of
work done on this and the officers both
uh in the
Democratic Services looking at the the
wires away for the North or the working
party
uh I don't profess you know that area
really well they had a small Beach area
Community Partnerships by your bike uh
but I know Stone room it does stand on
its own and it you know it doesn't link
very well we we even wherever that is
[Music]
but but anyway uh I I don't think it's
in our gift to be honest to turn this
down if if 50 people turn up to a
meeting in North Wingfield I think
that's a big success that that is is up
hunting out 50 people in one room uh in
a community lifestyle rule that means
this there's some uh some passion for
that so I just want some advice really
they're aware does it leave I know the
recommendation
comes there uh to not establish a
separate Parish Council if with this
meeting today both against that
recommendation where does it leave us
excuse me thank you um yes and you can't
actually vote the opposite way because
that would obviously negate the motion
what you'd effectively be doing is
sending it back to the working group to
look again perhaps carry out more
consultation
Etc
um with the reasons why you want that
done
and could I just say that would mean we
wouldn't hit the May elections you know
foreign
[Music]
um it's the Charlotte and high-end
Parish Council which could hold a
referendum
okay uh Council Q-tip followed by
councilor reader then counselor
thank you again
um
so I'll be honest with you I really
wrestle uh with this decision
um and whilst I've now sort of decided
which way to go and obviously been
missing the debate I would say I
recognize and I accept a lot of the
points that have been raised and this
really is in the balance for me
um and I've basically just decided to
focus on on a couple of points that have
sort of made my mind look
um throughout this this process I'm
consciously not expressed an opinion
firstly because I can see both of the
pros and cons to it that have been
mentioned but primarily because it's one
of the award members I thought it was my
responsibility to listen and so I've
tried to speak to many residents on the
latter as possible to get preferences
not just in terms of a yes or no and the
separate Council but also the reasons
that people have got and for me I think
there's two key questions the first one
is would a separate Parish Council
actually make sense
whilst not in comparison to the big town
councils I do think that there's a lot
of the responses highlight this is quite
a large Parish overall especially
compared to even brackenfield and
Westington that are just in the same
ward which have 200 and 500 residents
and I know it's it's debated in in the
report
um but it is to me stone room is a clear
area I think you've mentioned that
councilor Barker with its own identity
that is under consideration for a parish
council here it's not an individual
Street or anything like that but that's
in for a parish council calls me quite
concerned
um but it is you know Stone boom is
already a village in its own right and
it does have its own Community groups
and products and works with other areas
both in and out of the parish
so the second question for me and this
is the key one for that I've sort of
used really then becomes is there a wish
for it and I take points of the working
group and I think it is a balance
um because as councilor Lewis said at
the base level you want to make sure
there are enough residents with the time
and enthusiasm to put themselves forward
for election as a parish Chancellor
particularly if you have an extra
Council and for me this is where I put
the most weight on the consultation
responses
um I've spent a lot of time over the
weekend reading through all the appendix
responses and I taken except the reports
and you know the points in the report
and the debate that the response rate
has been relatively limited
um but I think that's in the context of
the whole parish and I am swayed by the
still strong number of replies in quite
a short period of time and we've
mentioned the reasons for that so I
don't criticize that and by the strength
of feeling and overall vote in this case
and so that's that's probably the most
compelling argument for me here
um and I know there are other factors
that we need to weigh up but the biggest
one for me that came through in the
consultation responses and and to be
fair it's one I've seen in practice as a
ward member since 2015 is that there are
a lot of different villages in this
parish and the parish council always has
a need to balance as we do as a district
council as a whole the different
communities of Sharon and Ryan
Broome Nicoli and Toad Hall furnace as
well which is quite often forgotten and
very often they do want the same things
and it's really easy and they share
facilities but sometimes they do want
and need different things and I've heard
that frustration in all the different
Villages and even despite the best
efforts of the parish council and I
would just take this moment just to pay
tribute to the current charity Parish
Council and the majority of the parish
councilors who I do work closely with
and I know that they're trying to do the
best for the whole parish and work
tirelessly you know hours and hours and
meetings and meetings in this regard
and so I'm straight I'm swayed by the
sort of strength of feeling here I think
the very fact that there's a sizable
group of residents who've taken the time
to have their saying and they've put
forward you know rational argument to me
and want to get involved and be active
in the community and that influences me
um so for me and it is in the balance
and sort of listens and it's not changed
my mind today I'm going to do what I
said a consultation and what I said to
Residents all the way through
um and I'm going to follow the majority
of consultation responses so I can't
support the draft recommendation today
as I would support the responses in
favor of a separate so you bring Parish
Council but having said that I just
wanted to make just a couple of final
points on a wider level I think that
today is a big decision one way or
another but I am confident there is a
way forward whichever way we go today
and whichever way the chamber decides
there's so much that unites all the
parishes I mentioned not least many
generations families from friends
including my own that live across them
and so as long as I'm one of the ward
members and I think it's advised to
council Lewis Leger and Roe as well if
the decision is made to form a separate
Parish Council in due course it's to me
it's not a declaration of independence
with any of Trump's wall or anything
like that and I'll support Place working
in collaboration in the same way we
already do across the different parishes
award to share office resources and
hopefully a good rather than about that
is and I think that already happens you
know in and out of the parish with
Morton too that neighbors uh stonebroom
and the you know the community
activities that I mentioned
but equally if the decision of the
chamber today isn't to go for a sort of
effect the parish council to pursue that
further
um I'll continue to try and work with
the parish council groups and residents
canvas try and canvas a wider section of
opinion and to work on some of the
solutions that have been sort of
mentioned uh you know in terms of trying
to solve some of the concerns raised so
that I just wanted to put that in saying
that it's not it's not be all an end-all
today uh to me and it is in Balance but
thank you thank you councilor reader
can you hear me yeah
um I think for me uh Charlotte you've
summed it up really you you know
Community identity is such a huge thing
for people where you come from where you
live it's within you and it's so
important to have that so if you're not
identifying with another part of that
Community you do have to weigh that up
and consider it and like you say you've
got that strong opinion that's coming
through from quite a number of people
that are raising that they don't see
themselves identifying with that other
section it's sad but you know they've
raised it so I think for me that is a
really key point that is sort of making
my mind up in which way I would be going
um so again I have to sort of say I
can't really support the recommendation
because for me that strong feeling is
coming through from those residents and
I have to sort of go with what councilor
bark is saying he's you know he's saying
that does that opinion man they want to
see their own Parish Council and their
own identity within it
so again I mean I've wrestled with it as
well you know councilor Welton brought
it up earlier you know forming that
identity within the name as well you
know as a Way Forward
um and I appreciate all the work that's
gone into it but again you've got strong
opinion there and it's it's coming
readily you know that they want
Standalone and you can see that when you
just drive through Stone room it is a
standalone Community isn't it
foreign
as well
um but if four percent it is a a woman
threshold I I don't I personally don't
think it is because of the castle Barker
said if you suddenly get people in a
room arguing for the same thing in a
community that is massive these days it
just doesn't happen and to get 161
responses I think is massive as well to
be honest with you as well particularly
when I suspect most of them looking at
the book came from the community that's
most affected by and the community that
most most wants that this change the
whole purpose of parishes to me is that
they cover sweet communities they are
the voice of that community in a way
that we are not because we straddle
communities you know I covered by
parishes and five different communities
that I cover three as the district
council I'm gonna have to balance that
but Parish councils just represent those
communities and nothing else
um
the other aspect that Council Frost is
alluded to is that the uh quantity side
of it the sheer number of people taking
part but there's also the quality side
of it and what would the community have
to have done not just getting more
people to take part in it but what more
would they have to have done to
demonstrate
that they wanted in terms of the
criteria it would be interested to know
what the panel thought of that and then
my question really is a technical
question uh for for service downberg
if we were to vote against this what
happens next you know those of us who
want to make sure that uh perhaps they
can all give them the position is that
they have a parish and consultation
consultation text based on the
sympathetic will take place like and it
won't take place what do we need to do
in terms of procedurally to do that do
we just put simply vote against it or do
we have to put down an amendment
um if you vote against the draft
recommendations you obviously can't as I
said previously put a
um an alternative opposite
um recommendation in place you would
have to send it back to the working
group to reconsider and perhaps we
consult so I would suggest that's what
you would do you would put in a
recommendation to return it to the
working group and for them to be
consoled
so just need something it just needs one
of us who have spoken this like that's
the constitute the monster that I'll be
more than happy to suspect it
you would need to go to all my main uh
recommendation first
language
thank you chair
um this is It's kind of the opposite of
what we were talking about earlier isn't
it because this is putting power into
the hands is very very local people
um no criticism of anyone over the
working group or any Parish Council
whatsoever but I I speak with people in
Old talk to them which is capital
between three parishes
um we have
husband and Winston which are part of
Russell Parish Council again they feel
that they've lost their identity and the
people in Stonebridge I think it's the
same thing
um totally take on board what Mark has
said that it is a very low Turner or
equally safe we have that turn out in
the general election 74 of people voted
battle for the result so I think it's
it's impossible for us not to recognize
that
um so and that they the feeling is there
people are wanting it I I think it in my
honest opinion I think it's wrong with
us to deny it to them and I I will be
um thanking um Council together soon
positions here and I'm recommending that
it goes back to go back to the working
group Council Shipman
it says
yeah
I
do
I'm counselor the district next to kill
him and that area
I believe it has got its own identity
it's now a village in some right
chairland and stone room are large
enough now to be self-sufficient and I
do think so we deserve that opportunity
to become a separate Parish
thank you chair
um we've just had a debate turned on
about devolution
um and now here we are talking about
somebody else who wants to have the
right to their own
power and so on control of their own
community so it feels very ironic to me
that we're uh even now thinking that we
might not let them have that challenge
I just want to see clarification about
the um the way that we're voting though
because when we did have
that item seven and the Devolution deal
update
at that point we were allowed to have
recommendations thrown into the mix and
then we voted on those recommendations
which led to something else so why now
when we've got
item 11 can we not add recommendations
great
um I don't understand why this is
different from what we just did at item
seven so I would like to think that we
could actually have recommendations here
because we've got to facilitate this
moving forward and that if the people's
film room want I'll call it Independence
they can they have what's uh rightfully
theirs so we can we just hope
to work yes
what you will be doing here is without
um doing any further work saying you
disagree with the working party that's
been set up to look at the matter it
should go back to the working party for
them to like that if you're referring to
you're referring to the Devo deal
decision earlier that wasn't an opposite
that wasn't a negative
amendment that was a one that was
focusing on the consultation in a
different way it was not the same
Barry
you said we'll miss the bay election and
is that massive but I mean even if we
recommend this he wouldn't
want them
yeah
um
is it working yes or if you remember the
last council meeting it was the
timetable was set up and it was a very
quiet time scale to try and get it to
the May elections if the new Irish
council is decided upon but yes you
haven't got that decision today
therefore we couldn't meet a timetable
to get it ready for the May elections
whatever decision you took in January
is it the clarification
can I ask them if we were to vote for
this most
if we were to vote for it
it goes out the consultation if the
response does not come back in say that
no we still want a separate Parish at
the next meeting in January could we
then
um vote for the question I said for
Parish at that stage
good night
because because the whole purpose of the
consultation is to ask people what they
think if they say that this is they
don't agree with this recommendation
is that the end of the process
completely or can we or can we then go
ahead with the uh placing on a separate
parish for I'm just trying to think
whether we can overcome this timing
difficulty yeah
um and certainly January the 30th
Council was set to achieve that
um off the top of my head I would
imagine you could do that but I would
have to look at it
to give a definitive answer
okay
clarification yeah and I think the
monitoring officers interpretation of
that rule is wrong because we are voting
on recommendations here the motion is
not we will not allow that to continue
it's a recommendation from a working
group to say that they recommend to us
the full Council that we won't go down
that route at any point of pause as the
actual Authority which is full
accounts and that recommendation
to something else it's not like a motion
where it's calling on a specific thing
they're just recommending two full caps
or something which I think we can
overturn and I think we could change
that motion to say that we disagree with
that working party and that we think
there should be a further consultation
um for the people of Stoneboro
yeah
just to clarify you want to be able to
move around an amendment
wants to say that we disagree with the
working party's assumptions or or
recommendation and that we think that it
should go to consultation
the further consultation there which is
what you know I think we can because
it's only a recommendation from that
working partner
and get promotion on the table in that
case I amend that motion to say that we
disagree with that working part as
assumptions and that is
should with this Council agreeing that
it should be evolved and separated
but we cannot we can turn down any
recommendations of changing as we see
further you turn them down but you can't
just amend a motion to the opposite
start no cards you can't negate the
motion
questions on someone
yeah can I just ask if we
the the working party are told to go
back and revisit it and then they come
back and say what was doing what we're
study in first place what happens
because there's got to be a remix
somewhere for those people of stormbrew
to be able to have their voice heard and
you if you've got three people that are
the working committee they've given us
this recommendation so they've had
they've done the work and I'm not
knocking your work but you've done the
work that you think it is and you've
come up with this result so what
difference would it be because you're
probably going to get the same people
coming back again yeah uh the same
people attending new messages same
people you know replying to you what
would you be doing that's different that
would make you change your mind to come
back and say well actually yeah we do
think we should be able to do it how how
does that work because I can't see you
going away and getting anything any
different to what you've got now so
we've got to have a Way Forward
of moving this so that the people's dorm
room can have because it sounds to me
the majority of people in this room
believe that storm broom should have
their own Parish now if that's the case
why why are we messing up because going
backwards and folders is not going to
help the people of stone group and you
know regardless of dates we've got to
find a way forward with it and I think I
think what we perhaps should do is get
the feeling of this room about what they
think about it and then actually I have
a reason way forward to Amendment so
that we can pass what the majority of
this Council want
thank you
okay we're going to adjourn for five
minutes so it can be reconsidered and
how to break thrown in at the same time
no tea I'm sorry no you can share one of
my losses okay
foreign
as I'm sure you all agree this is an
extremely important issue for the local
community and we have several members of
the public here today who have asked to
address the council in order to do this
I intentionally join the meetings for a
short time and I'm prepared to allow
three people to see they will each have
three minutes and the class will inform
them when they have 30 seconds left
I have already spoken conditions so I
think they're lined up for who's
speaking to what I'm going to start with
councilor lomack
thank you very much Jeff I'm Alistair
Max
um I'm a member of
Sherling and high in Parish Council and
I'm a resident Stonebrook
um I just want to share some of my
experiences as the parish account
include in that particular Council and
tell you why I'm in favor of Stoneham
having its own Parish Council first of
all it's an issue of size
um we have over 4 000 electors in our
parish and when you consider that about
80 percent of the parishes in England
have elect as populations of about two
and a half thousands we are overly large
and that leads to a structural problem
which means that as far as stoneware
residents are concerned uh the setup in
terms of our local government now Parish
isn't working for us it that means that
there's electors Stone room is only
represented by third of the total
electorate for the walk for the for the
actual Parish which means that there are
about four Stone Brewing councils
against 12 for the rest
as as a third more or less of the parish
councilors or what happens is that and
from my experience that
um when issues have come up that are
very important to Stone Brewing
residents these are Beacon these have
been consistently
uh ignored and faulted simply because
we've been outvoted and simply because
the issues that have come from stoneware
residents have been projected on the
grounds of their problems you have 30
seconds okay so I think
uh it's important to tell you that as
far as what stoma ready to say to me is
they feel disenfranchised and they don't
have a real voice through the present
Parish structure so I hope you listen to
what's been said from from those
resonance
and that you will give us our voice and
regain some of the trust that has been
lost in local democracy thank you very
much thank you
I have another speaker here with Mrs
Julia Smith
I have ladies John from 26 years and I
was at the meeting uh there were 50
people there but the guy that seems to
think that they were all in favor of it
I'm not sure they were I think there was
a lot of mixed messages and I think a
lot of people whose dorm room don't
really understand what it will mean
whether it's for the good I'm still on
the friends myself but I think more
people need to to know more the leaflets
that came through the door didn't really
explain it very easily for a lot of
people
that's all
thank you
I've been from one other speakers
someone else wishes to speak
no okay we'll move on thank you
Council pupits a few words thank you
chair um I think based on thank you for
the adjournment I think based on uh the
discussion and sort of taking into
account maybe some feedback The Proposal
if you sell from Council Foster are
happy to amend the draft recommendation
is basically exactly what um the
resident was just saying advantages
currently then uh that basically we go
back out to consultation on this but we
make it an open-ended one so we say that
these are the responses we've had so far
and go back out to consultation
delegating back to the working group to
sort of do the mechanics of that and as
part of that more information can be
given about what a parish council mean
and then also it provides people an
opportunity those who haven't haven't
responded to have that say that you know
oh it is leaning as part of the
consultation towards a separate parish
council at that point a lot of people
can come forward and say oh we're not
sure about that or a lot of people
forward and say yeah I think that's the
right way but I'd be happy if I think
Council Costa's got amended
recommendation don't ask me to encrypt
it and be I'd be supportive of that
yeah
thank you chair um thank you
uh
yeah uh before
a talk on the the amendment I'll speak
just briefly on some of the points that
were brought so
um there was only one question which
I'll come to uh we've heard uh Castle
Barker said they don't want it and you
mentioned about I think I've just
covered this in the break with you but
they don't want
um
yeah at the parish council
um that they don't want a referendum I
think you might be surprised
uh I think you might be on that uh what
I envisaged later on if this if if these
recommendations have been accepted and
we'd have come back to council it was
perhaps even uh suggesting to the parish
council that they do carry out a
referendum uh we've got experience in
the working group of ones that have been
carried out already to the cost and what
sort of response you get from them and
that would have added a different flavor
to the consultation we carried out so
that's the sort of thing I would have
looked at next uh size-wise uh as
someone's uh mentioned there I think it
was councilor Lomax it wouldn't be out
of the way uh there's enough residence
there 1472 and that's the electorate and
there are some clearly defined
boundaries we knew that during the uh
while we were formulating the
recommendations and we spoke about it
quite a lot uh we mentioned uh
there uh Council Lomax mentioned and
this is real important this because this
came out that the at the uh at the
consultation meeting when we had 50
people turn up uh and councils I see
councilor Barnes in the
um in the gallery as well uh there's 12
from my understanding there's 12 people
there's 12 members on the parish council
and four from stonebroom and yes over
and over again and I think you know what
I'm going to say I asked over and over
again uh give me some examples of that
give me some examples when stonebroomer
put something forward still room
counselors and it's been turned down or
worked against by other members that
didn't live in storm room and I asked
that repeatedly if an interesting four
or five times uh yeah and offices were
there too and I couldn't get any there's
not one uh example I'm still ready
through those examples where people put
things forward like they might have put
a particular I don't know whatever idea
they put forward and wanted to do for
stone room or wanted to stop a stone
room it just didn't come out there was
nothing there we took no record of it at
all and I asked the question four or
five times so we made an effort with
that so for me it may just be and I
tried to get to the bottom of this when
a chat that meets and it may just be
they've got disagreements on a council
and you can't call it dysfunctional
because many of these Parish councils
work like that's certainly multiple and
most of the ones I've been to the the
very you know the places where you have
disagreements
uh when it comes to we've mentioned
quite a few times that people have said
that there's some comments over there
that are so it's about a 74 I'm talking
about turnout not to the turnout's
actually four percent and it's 74 of
that four percent which is three percent
the whole Parish of one state so so
let's let's try and keep that uh in mind
it's not 74 percent at all it's a four
percent turnout uh there was only one
question uh which councilor Jill uh put
tonight and that was qualitative and
we've spoken about the quantity quite a
lot but when it comes to the quality of
the actual responses and we have to be
careful I would say this it's how people
write and it's how people respond when
you actually look at the hard copies of
what people sent back they were some
good quality knowledgeable replies there
were some but there are also many people
that just wrote We want it and you can't
give the same although it's somebody's
view you can't give the same sort of
value on that and place the same weight
on that because that's what our guidance
said it says specifically we should be
looking at the quality of the of the
response and that's why you've got these
recommendations here that you might not
necessarily people might not necessarily
agree with that's why the response came
from the working group because of the
quality and because of the number the
quantity as well that the quality as
we've heard it it is in there it's
included in there
um so that's that's the answer to the
answer to the actual debate uh based on
what council Cupid has said I've now got
the amendment I hope that's useful by
the way
um So based on the views of the council
and the consultation responses received
the council asks the working groups
carry out further more extensive
consultation into the possibility of a
separate storm room Parish Council as
part of this
the views expressed by Council will be
will be relayed to consult that's
actually the country you're writing it's
not mine
so that the council can reconsider the
original uh recommendations
okay uh petition
so uh yeah all right uh so yeah so we're
happy to look at this again I'm also
happy to take uh suggestions which I'll
happily take outside this meeting if
anybody wants to email me with ideas for
our working group we're really open to
that
um so if you've got any ideas I'm happy
to all those all those Parish meetings
again I'm happy to put the the surveys
out again is something we can do uh
we're not close to uh still room having
a separate Parish Council not at all but
we just didn't have the evidence to be
able to recommend to this Council we're
happy to go look it again based on what
the you've heard thank you Jim thank you
Council Barker yeah yeah I think
listening to that I think I've got the
idea
yeah I can accept that I think you've
listened to the debate and the the
there's feelings in the meeting that
that uh I think we support film room
having their own Parish Council but you
need evidence to justify that and fully
accept that so if if you go in with that
open mind that that stone room
uh you just need more evidence as to why
Stonebrook should have its own Parish I
believe is that what you're asking for
and if people get involved with that
I can go along with that recommendation
to move us on thank you
any further comments
no
happy to second that I mentioned that's
where we can move to the vote
hands up everyone
definitely
that's Carrie thank you very much
[Music]
public participation we've received no
questions from the public
and we move on to item 13. to answer any
questions from Members under procedural
rule 9.2 in accordance with Council
petunia rule 9.2 to allow members to ask
questions about Council activity the
replies to any such questions will be
given to the chair of the council the
relevant can you see of the appropriate
Cabinet member
questions must be received in writing
none have been received today
moving on to item 14 to consider any
motions from Members under the
procedural number 10. and motion a has
been modified accounts and Alex scale
thank you very much Chad um I'm not
going to speak the log on this for the
obvious reason
um obviously there's previously been a
council position around fracking
um we've been opposed to the tracking I
think that's pretty much been on a
cross-partum basis you know across
across the floor all of us have agreed
that we don't support that in Northeast
Derbyshire and and rightly so and and
obviously several of us as individual
cameras have been and been pretty
heavily involved in the campaign
particularly at March Lane uh from New
Orlean at Marsh Lane
um the other point I've just made is
that many within our group were
obviously very concerned by the
government's decision to lift the
moratorium we didn't support it we made
our position pretty clear as a group uh
and I'm very pleased that that
moratorium has been reinstated
um I'm hoping that we can all put aside
sort of any politics and just all
support this Motion in the way that we
have done with previous motions acutely
conscious that we have two motions on
the table one from Ross later
um they are quite similar in many in
many respects but I'll acutely aware
that two points on which Ross's motion
has that that mine doesn't I think to
speak move things along and speed it up
I'm really happy to accept both of those
additions to my motion so I'm going to
suggest that we add a new point three uh
which would say right to garbage against
Council asking the authority to include
provision for 500 meter exclusion zones
around any exploratory or fracking
drilling sites within their draft
minerals bun and then a number a new
number four would be calls on the
government to introduce a complete ban
on fracking in the UK and then the
existing points three and four would
become points five and six so those two
new points in the middle it makes more
sense that they go there and hopefully
cancer treatment happens a second you
yeah sure thank you and I will second
that motion obviously those two bits
that have been added into this first I
should make absolutely perfect so for
now I'll withdraw the next one as well
um and I've been setting this thank you
I think it's really good to hear what
was that a second from the cross party
um in terms of My Views I think there
there may be those who think fracking is
the answer to the energy crisis and
almost 20 years of being a counselor I
have met two such people
however the overwhelming view of
residents I talked to is that bracking
is not welcome in our district
have never wavered from our view that
the brachium is totally unacceptable in
our Ward and in the district
fracking is the biggest threat to our
Countryside it is opposite to all we are
trying to achieve in our battle against
climate change
it has no place in a zero carbon future
evidence suggests that Shale gas
extraction can cause air and sound
pollution
evidence suggests that toxic chemicals
used to frac can find its way into
waterways and harm wildlife
so let me be clear in my opinion
drilling to extract fossil fuel fuels is
not a solution to the energy crisis
on behalf of residents I represent and
those that Peter who presents we say no
to fracking in Northeast Derbyshire and
we support this motion
thank you Council Barker
yeah thank you sorry Alex
got to be a bit of politic than it all
right again okay and where is a bit
surprised to see this on agenda uh and
and I've got to question where uh I
wonder why you've already gone uh
I might be a bit cynical but I suspect
the motivation for it might be down to
cover up what to both rmps voted for a
little while ago at Parliament and he's
trying to cover somebody's back with
this uh and if that's the rationale I
don't think it'll work personally I
think the residents are rackington and
kill the marsh Cole Aston and dronfield
uh I'll not forget our work certain
people voted in that when they walk
through that to that Lobby uh and we'll
keep reminding them
but uh and again I told you about uh
added a couple of bits there I mean we
may want to say it's not just about
Northeast Derbyshire which you've added
in that bit it's got to be a United
Kingdom ban on cracking it's not just
about than any in this little bit you
start to fracking in balls over I think
we'll we'll get the repercussions of
that I had written another amendment
which again I've I've asked I wanted to
print out it's not massive and I can
accept what you've added in your in this
one that Ross has submitted it does
change uh paragraph one
uh welcomes the decision of the
government to reverse its recent
decision to lift the morator it's not a
new government it's it's the same
government we're different people looked
up on it and and then added another
paragraph which will now be number seven
uh and it goes on the four group leaders
or in the absence of unanimity the
majority group leaders to write jointly
in the name of the council to the new
the two members of parliament
representing the residents of Northeast
do I expressed the council's opposition
to hydraulic bracket anywhere in the
United Kingdom and not just in
Derbyshire obviously we I wrote that
before uh that them amendments were made
but I'll go back to my first point
uh I think it's it's trying to cover
somebody's bike
thank you
are there any other comments
counselor now I'm sorry but this it is
needlessly blitzizing the issue I can't
support it the the point about the
members of parliament is just Factory
and correct they voted against allowing
time for a debate on America they did
not vote for fracking it is factually
incorrect to suggest that they did and I
just don't accept it if you look at what
they actually Rose before what the
motion on the table was in Parliament on
that day it was not what you think it is
it's not what the labor party is
starting at the moment just factually
incorrect the second point I'll make is
that it's not just it's not just uh the
the government at the time that's that
voted to live in the moratorium but it
was supported by the Trade union
movement as well GMB came out and very
positively endorsed the lifting of that
moratorium so there are there are views
across the political Spectrum around
fracking and that's an uncomfortable
truth which I'm sure you don't
particularly like but this motion is
just ridiculous we had a decent motion
it was uh it was cross-party agreed and
I don't see that really for adopting the
the amended version at all I just asked
you can withdraw it and let's get on
with the meeting
[Music]
that's why I can't see your name Council
Pickering sorry
I just want to second
Amendment
thank you
okay the floor's open now to discuss the
amendment
yeah any comment Council shipment
yeah I think given the
um version of the two motions a bit
forward I really think that this
amendment should probably be ball if
we're being honest um it's not really
achieving anything extra and I think the
original motion now actually does what
we all or how we all want which is to
cover the national band and fracking
another thing it's we're just wasting
our time
any other comments
no Okay so
we have to vote on the amendment
oh sorry thank you
thank you chair I mean the key the key
part of this says uh councilor Barker
said is uh our elected local
Representatives
to protect constituents in Northeast
Derbyshire for both campaign
um against fracking in Northeast
Derbyshire and supported not having a
ban on fracking go to the moratorium
which is only temporary
and has been proved just recently in
Parliament on a whim of the weather's
leading that Parliament it can change
we had a moratorium under one prime
minister we had it lifted under another
without it put back under another one
it's like watching the chuckle Brothers
It's to me to you to me to you uh it's
all on a whim if they're an outright ban
on fracking then it would take all that
angst and pain from communities that are
under threat of it at this moment in
time I know this one now is just said to
campaign for a van on fracking we need
to include campaigning to our MPS on
that and this District council's got an
important uh message to give to those
MPS and it's not just about Northeast
Derbyshire if we don't want to increase
road traffic Road pollution millions of
gallons of untreatable polluted water
that's going to be trickled into our
river systems if that's not acceptable
in Northeast Derbyshire it's not
acceptable nationally we shouldn't just
have it in our a bit of nimbyism on
what's appropriate in our backyard we
should go for an all-out National ban
and that includes our elected
representatives getting on that and not
just exploiting it for personal
political gain in local elections thank
you councilor Hancock thank you chair
having to with absolute respect to
councilor Sparkle and Pickering I think
that the key point is that the amount of
motion that's been booked Council
already is to cut includes the line to
call on the government to introduce a
complete ban on fracking across the UK
so that there's no nimdianism in there
and I respect that yours was written
prior to this amended one kind of being
in place well this has been over been on
the agenda all along so they have kind
of both been there
so I I think given that it's not
actually asking for anything different
to what's already in the promotion I
don't see the point
thank you
thank you chair
um I wasn't going to respond to council
speaker's comments but I actually
feel quite strongly about your last
statement almost accusing people of
doing these things and saying these
things just because we want to do one in
someone who's been council's nearly 20
years have been saying these sorts of
messages
month in month out week in week out year
in year out and for you to then perhaps
even hint
and we're saying what we're saying today
for any other
ulterior motive is totally
unacceptable unacceptable
and I'm not interested Council Morley so
we've been talking about
fracking and this is an opportunity to
come together as all parties not play
games and you've just heard a second
name from Liberal Democrats you know
that we don't always see eye to eye read
the rule it was a clue
we don't always see eye to eye or read
the room this is an opportunity for us
all to come together and show the people
we represent note of bracking in
Northeast Derbyshire because that's
where we represent
and I don't think I should apologize for
that Cameo thank you
I want to leave the motion as it's done
uh and and they don't negate anything
that's in there I'm not taking apart
from that a couple of words in that
number one just to actually correct it
well everything else can stay in we're
just having another paragraph and if you
don't I'll keep working at it and we'll
we'll go on for a minute
Council Adele you have the right to
reply
even even if the point isn't level that
local councilors around the around doing
this for election purposes I just think
that's completely factually Incorrect
and you know to defend our MP he was
there at the planning committee meeting
in in the County Council he was there at
the planning appeal he was crashing
withinios he's done thousands of
Resident letters hundreds of meetings
around the issue I just don't think it's
really fair you know take a point you
know try and score political points and
that's all it is really when we talk
about motions uh items your Amendment
with point five calling on the MPS you
know that they didn't vote for fracking
you know that that's absolutely not true
but it's it it's you know it's good
political points going we have an
opportunity here to vote for a
cross-party emotion let's just do that
but if you're going to put forward
devotion then I'll vote against
hopefully we can all support the
original amended motions it stands
okay
members the voting on the amendment
burst and then after that we will vote
on the main motion whether amended or
not
I'll read your names counselor P Wright
counselor B Wright
councilor p wingley
yes
councilor welcome
so
Stephenson
Council Shipman against
Council Ross against
Council house
he's gone
again that's the Ridgeway yeah
Council redmi
Council reader
oh
Council pal
yes that supports yes
of that
that's a Pickering yeah that's the
parking there goes that's the Molly oh
that's a legit again Council Lewis
that's the Lacy oh
councilor Kerry four four
Council Canyon
right
Council Jones
oh
okay
[Music]
councilor
Council for now okay that's the end
poster okay
[Music]
councilor Emmons
he's gone
Council Elliot
cancer Dayton yes Council Dale Council
against Council Cooper that's a good
luck
no
and Council angel
thank you
okay the results from the amendment
the result was 14 4 28 against and no
abstentions
the motion was depicted
we can now move on to the main motion
and we're doing that all again by our
own course
yes yes
as before this is the motion and I will
do names your names tell me or against
the word saying Council P right
that's a b right
or that's the Tate that's a so that's a
Stratford Stevenson or Council shipment
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
Council Jones or
Council Hart's home
that's a Hancock four Council Hall he's
not yeah casagon is really
Council that's it for now oh that's the
end posture
Council Elliott
Council dating
cool that's a cute pitch for
eign
experience that was unanimous I didn't
answer that up thank you
moving on to motion B
is presented by a counselor William Lee
councilor Hancock are you going to
secondly because banking
Council no council budgets are used for
a variety of Grant schemes a lottery
scheme would be self-funding and provide
additional resources to local community
groups and Charities on the voluntary
petition participation basis unlike
taxation
but also the district council and
Mansfield District Council run Lottery
schemes and could offer advice on
setting one up the funding generated
could be used to help organizations
helping families get through the cost of
living crisis
Council resolves to start its own
Lottery scheme using the amounts of
generators to fund the scheme and then
splitting the remaining 50 50 between
the winners and funding local community
groups and Charities that apply
councilor hand coach Mr second uh I'm
happy today I'll reserve the right
students thank you councilor Foster
thank you chair uh go and I'll make a
start on this uh it's a subject close to
my art uh I can't support a lottery
scheme at all uh even though you've got
in their voluntary participation on like
taxation
uh for me it's it's when you look at who
pays for this uh I think of mayo not my
own experiences but I'm experienced with
other people that have been involved in
things like luxuries when I look
a lot of gamblins now moved online
a lot of it has and it's difficult to
say who actually is spending that money
online and how it's affecting people
because of the people that actually
collect that information all the
gambling companies so it's difficult to
say who's actually affected by it but if
you look at traditionally the people
that are affected by gambling if you
look at betting shops I'm thinking of
the ones I know off the top of my head
wanting to wrong field we've got one at
Clay Cross and one Atkinson if you look
at the people that have stood outside
those places they're not the richest
people
they're not the people that have got the
most money
um there are a certain section for me a
society that does use these uh the
disease packaging shots if you look at
scratch cards and I think I want to see
people buy scratch cards for me I see
them when I'm in uh when I pay for my
petrol there's somebody in front of me
and they never look like the the four
people they look like
people that are less affluent I'll say
like that if we look at the people that
spend money in Amusement arcades on
things like fruit machines I think those
are a certain section about Society
people that are less affluent again so
for me it's very often little that's
kind of our poorest residents now you
shouldn't judge a book by its cutter but
for me
well you can't object to it afterwards
put your hand up an objective afterwards
but while I'm saying it now this is my
own View and I feel quite strongly about
it you shouldn't judge that book by its
cover but when you look at how gambling
affects people and how it affects
communities
to finish
yeah
when you look how it affects communities
I think it has I don't think it is well
from it at all we're looking at standing
there if we were to set this up you'll
be looking at a 50 50 payout or leaving
group machines were kind of minimum 75
payout so for me I think it's uh I think
it's quite an immoral thing to set up
and I know everybody at this lab I've
spoken first I don't intend on going
with what most people uh feel on this
but these are my own feelings about
introducing gambling and the the money
takes off a certain section of our
society so I don't expect everybody to
get their roommate agree with me on this
but it's you know it's not the way
forward
thank you Jay thank you any other
comments
I've got councilor Dale councilor Wilton
Elsa Barry councilman
thank you Jack uh am I on yeah uh thank
you open to exploring it
um but from a process point of view I
don't think we should be making a
decision
um of this level of significance on the
basis so quite a short motion and no
offense to the you know I appreciate why
you put the motion on but it doesn't it
doesn't it's not a rapport that details
some of the pros cons the costs the any
potential unintended consequences uh I
think there are some ethical
considerations here you know I I do have
some degree of a you know discomfort
with the idea of promoting gambling at a
time when we are in the midst of a cost
of living crisis I get that these are
these are Community doctors they are for
good causes I do understand understand
that and there might be some benefits
but it is still a form of gambling and
you know I do have some sort of
philosophical views on that I'm not
saying I'm completely against it but you
know there are important considerations
that we ought to think about before
reaching a decision like this there's
also the cost spoken to the finances and
the resources opposite time I know that
there are organizations who effectively
run these lotteries for the council I
was actually contacted by one very
recently
um who were touting the business
um but it does come at a cost either to
the council in terms of paying that
organization to run it or it comes in
cost of Officer time or actually both
because quite often the organization
will do so much but you do have to do
front load some of the work from your
own officers as well and when I say
costs I don't just mean Financial costs
I mean opportunity lost costs we've got
um you're all aware that we've got a
huge number of really important projects
things like the crack of the Town deal a
lot of the Leisure Center projects uh UK
SPF there's a huge amount going on at
the moment and a bit low to divert
officer time to this not saying that
it's a necessarily a bad thing it's it
could it could have some some Merit but
at the moment I just don't think it's
the right time in terms of that officer
capacity so I'm not completely against
the principle open to exploring it but I
have concerns about what weather right
now is a good time to do it and whether
it's actually the right thing to do at
all
um so I I can't support the motion as it
currently stands thank you chair thank
you councilor Wilton
right a little bit quick uh thank you
chair
um despite the good intentions I'd have
to vote against this as well on ethical
grounds I don't believe in gambling
we're a free Society what people do in
private sector is up to Durham but the
public body I can't I can't support it I
think gambling is wrong it should be
more restricted and I know the huge
problems of addiction growing addiction
it is an addictive habit amongst the
growing sexual Society thank you thank
you Council Baron
thank you chair
um basically I think this is something
that could be looked hard to screw to me
at some point it doesn't need to be one
here I think that like I said there
could be possibilities that it might not
be totally understand uh where Council
Foster's coming from about the gambling
side of it and all the rest of it but it
is something I think we could we could
look in we can explore it if it's not a
Goa it's not a goal that's that's fine
but I will take offense at what
councilor Foster said about people and
looking like their gamblers are looking
like this or looking like that
I have to say I wouldn't have thought
myself as a government but I have a
caravan and on that side they have
old-fashioned two-piece slot machines
my kids do that they know the limit they
get a could end up they get a lot of
money they get they get a lot of fun of
it they won't wait and as long as you're
educating them
and you you know that's fine but don't
presume just because somebody looks a
bit scruffy or whatever that they are
the ones that are going to have this
habit that is
stereotyping people and we should not be
doing that
this is something that that goes to a
school day committee uh with some
recommendations after next May whoever's
in John Jack and they can have a proper
look at it exactly what he used to do if
we don't know what you've got what the
take looks like uh and I'm going to
return my year it's by a lottery ticket
I don't want to be serious job in that
game
that's the reason
thank you John I I again agree with the
sentiments of the motion you can
understand you know Community groups
they look for that kind of funding but I
do think we've got lots of schemes
already in place where Community groups
can can tap into it so there are many
different schemes you can you can access
for that
um including at county level I believe
there's there's other schemes there too
um I agree with my colleagues I think a
scrutiny committee would be a good place
to have the discussion and you can have
more of a exploration around the topic a
little bit more go more in depth of
seeing if it is something that we could
do but I absolutely agree with uh
Council Barry I think councilman Foster
when you look back at some of the
comments you made I think you want to
try and make the right sentiments but
they kind of come out a little bit wrong
um you can't judge a book by cover which
is what you said you absolutely can't
and I've seen many affluent people that
have got into trouble as well with
gambling so it can be on all spectrums
of society so I think we just need to
remember that thank you
councilor Johnson councilor backup
I was just going to
um
oh greatly
just about a museum
exactly the same as my colleagues have
said and especially about the language
used because
a lot of people like that vote on the
lottery it's about a wish to improve
their lives because there's something
about what's going on for them
but they go just go across old people
when people go to Royal ask at their
gambling and so
please don't do things like that because
everybody shouldn't be classed as
anything just because you presume that
thank you
thank you councilor backup thank you
thank you chair
um
I think the sake of one word in this
motion
things could be different and emotion
says to start a lottery but it changed
itself from start to to explore
the lottery having a lottery and it
means that we can do what we've all been
talking about which means it could go to
scrutiny and in the ways it Council
Dales just describe we can start to find
ways to perhaps launch it what would it
mean in terms of opposite time what
would that mean in terms of taking
offices away from Frontline Services
what companies could deliver this for us
we could go to Bulls over District
Council for example and find out what
works for them what doesn't work for
them we can start the um fact-finding
Mission and if it works for us let's
launch it but also we'd have to be
discussion about the um the morality of
it and so on and people can have a
discussion there but the fact of life in
the 23th century is this is how a lot of
fundraising happens for so many
organizations so many Charities and
ultimately while we know that some
people have addictions from whatever
Walk of Life you're from it's up to them
to decide whether to say the gamble or
not you know it's not a nanny saint
and so when Alice looked it was it
wasn't anyway so um I think we should we
should explore the idea of a lottery
just that one word change to make a
difference to this motion
councilman
all right thanks for that I'll I'll
definitely be voting against it but I
just want to point out on Saturday night
Clay Cross Parish Council donated nearly
4 000 pounds to local groups tennis
clubs tennis table tennis clubs
OIP a lot a lot to do and with four
thousand pounds bailout we also give 25
pounds to people over 60 TV licenses
that's what the play plus Parish does
and I think you're going to get off your
back sides and let your parishes run it
and let them see what they can do if
they can do what we can do I'm sure they
can do it so look at young balances look
at your preset and see what you can do
going to Lottery is a No-No it would
cost a fortune don't get me wrong we all
know what offices there's money on these
days very high and it's I'm not calling
that but it'll cost you Fortune you'd
never do it and how would you share
again you'd never do it thank you
councilman Foster
thank you chair I know I've spoken once
uh but it's a point of order uh personal
explanation
yeah uh I didn't mention the word
scruffy at all those words have been
pointing to my mouth but listening that
clear what I said was less affluence and
I still stand by that my concern is that
what section of society this is aimed at
and how it affects people and it's a
genuine concern
and that's it
thank you Jeff thank you any other
comments
thank you chair
um yeah to come back I think the key
thing and yes I do understand what
personal thoughts in Australian saying
and I do do take on board the point he's
trying to make I think
the reality is that much more like
Council vacca says these are this is a
regular thing that's from across
multiple ones and I think the sheer size
of one of those on offer means that it
doesn't really attract the sort of
people who are wanting to uh or who are
likely to fall into a gambling addiction
because that kind of money is never
liked itself so it self-regulates on
that basis
um I agree also with what council Barry
says that sometimes we have a role to
play in educated people and they can do
it sensibly and I think I think that's
also part of it
um yeah uh respect to what people say
about being expert perhaps that would be
a better wording and perhaps if Council
does turn it down it would be minded to
work with options in the future and I
think it's quite obvious it's not going
to get the support but I would say if
that could be walked out then you know
if I would soon be initiated
thank you another comment counseling you
do have a really right to reply thank
you okay we can move to
shall we do it by show of hands
it will be less time
okay those in favor of the motions
those against
emotions lost thank you
foreign
thank you chair would you be happy just
to take a slight change here because
Council Cupid wasn't proposing and
management while seeing us substantially
it's not changing much and I suggest
that I move I move the amended version
Council group is second it rather than
us go through go through the whole thing
of having like a pink one yeah
yeah
so so effectively the revised wording if
I can give that
Council notes between November and March
green bean collections are haunted by
Northeast Yorkshire District Council
many residents ask members sorry I'm
trying to read these words for
improvements to our system during the
Autumn winter months particularly given
the changes in our climate and the next
bit has kind of been struck there and
Council resolves to support plans to
extend the garden waste collection
period next year as well as looking at a
range of options to provide residents
with environmentally friendly options
for their green waves which may include
but not be limited to working with the
County Council and discouraging food
waste and encouraging the use of
compostable bags to food-based feelings
support with creating compost bins and
further advice on alternative ways to
reduce and dispose of green waste in a
way which is good for the environment
and I think the Crux of the motion is
there the environment is changing so
whilst when this measure of suspended
really means was first introduced it was
relevant I think the requirement has
changed how things are growing much
longer we've got the period now we're
actually Morton Lake some of my people's
grains are filling with leaves and such
at the moment they're struggling to get
rid of them while Greenville is a
suspender
so that's really the ethos behind us is
to adapt the services of where you're
living which we're changing need and so
on that basis I'll propose a motion
doesn't keep it yeah thank you thank you
chair
um yeah thank you councilor Hancock for
accepting that Amendment
um as you say I think it's always been
my aspiration personally as Cabinet
member to to bring this through
um always balancing climate change
considerations and councilor kenyan's
gone now so I can sneak it in while he's
not here but there was always that
balance of if you're driving around for
an emergency wagon what's the point but
it is clear that the climate's changing
as you said and in previous years we've
looked and have committed previously at
District Parish liaison to look at um
extending Garden waste and we just
haven't got around to it a because we
saw the national changes were coming
through which are now being tested in
Scotland and then being
um because obviously we've had the
pandemic and had enough issues with our
refuse services but uh yeah about six
weeks ago before I spoke to the council
and talk about this I'd put it in motion
with Street Scenes like extend this
because we've got another uh Street
Scene paper coming to Cabinet anyway so
we need to put that in so yeah I'm happy
to to Second the uh the amendment motion
I think Alan's got a few copies of it if
anybody needs it but cancer right now
thank you councilor Parker
copy that we'll
uh I think we're going to recommend this
because we'll go to school today but now
you've said that Charlotte I think
that's fine I think if you've made that
decision which is like you say things
are changing we
we don't have a win together well not
still students anyway
so yeah I think we can accept what
you've
done
any other comments
are made binoculars then
in which case if there's no comment
shall we go straight to the vote
I'm just going to do a show of hands
those in favor
anyone against
that's Gary thank you all
right
um
thank you
foreign